hey friends welcome back to deep dive in
this episode i am doing a conversation
with oliver berkman oliver is the author
of the incredibly real genuinely really
good book four thousand weeks time and
how to use it the book is in fact so
good that darren brown said i loved this
book and mark manson the famous author
of the subtle art of not giving a [ __ ]
said wonderfully honest a much needed
reality check on our culture's crazy
assumptions around work productivity and
living a meaningful life this is a
really good book it's kind of like a
productivity book but it's not really a
productivity book it's more like a
philosophical existential look at like
the finitude of existence and how we're
all gonna die and how like the whole
productivity guru culture stuff is maybe
not the appropriate way to live a
meaningful life so yeah really
wide-ranging conversation um oliver used
to be a journalist i think still is a
journalist at the guardian where for 10
years he wrote their column which was
called this column will change your life
and he talks about how it started off as
a bit of satire like poking fun at all
these productivity gurus but then what
he found as he was doing this is that
some of the productivity guru life
advice was actually kind of useful and
then it kind of became more of a sincere
thing but now he's written this book and
it's actually sick the thing i love
about oliver is that he's it's a very
like british approach to the idea of
productivity and living a meaningful
life and you know my uh our american
listeners will hopefully forgive me for
making the the the distinction between
like a very american approach to like
hustle and productivity this is a bit
more of a kind of low-key chilled out
british vibe where it's like hey we're
all gonna die let's not take things too
seriously um that kind of stuff so
definitely check the book out links are
gonna be in the video description and in
the show notes depending on whether
you're watching this on youtube or
listening to this on a podcast platform
of your choice and i hope you enjoyed
this conversation between me and oliver
berkman oliver welcome welcome to the
podcast welcome to the program welcome
to the show i i haven't quite figured
out what the terminology is it's like
radio 4 it's welcome to the program
american podcast is welcome to the show
what do you what do you think sounds
more legit ah yeah i i think show is
more common now right but if it's
programmer
um thank you for coming on uh
we are both considered productivity
gurus on the internet and broadly uh and
i i i was intrigued by how how how do
you feel about that uneasy
um is is that even
i suppose i must be i know you are i'm
very uneasy about it yeah no no i mean
you are considered one i don't know
yeah it's a strange it's a strange thing
isn't it because you're sort of
apart from anything else you're kind of
um if you spend a lot of time
thinking about this stuff and practicing
it and putting into practice
you you run up against its limitations
and its edges and you sort of see past
it so it always feels like you're kind
of anything that you've sort of put out
into the world is always like one step
behind what you're trying where your
thinking is at yeah i know what you mean
i've got thoughts on this but like how
how how did you become a productivity
guru what was the what was the path to
get here totally accidentally now i mean
i guess the main thing that i've done in
this area is is writing this for a long
time was writing this column for the
guardian
which started off like literally
so i did it for more than a decade and
it started off as um
basically just
uh mocking self help really like i mean
my main motive at the beginning we
called it this con will change your life
and that was meant to be a joke and i
spent the next like decade of my life
explaining to people it was meant to be
sardonic and um and it started off
mainly about like
looking at the sort of
mainly the nonsense that was that was in
the sector with a few little gems here
and there i'm afraid that was a kind of
a the journey was one of becoming more
sincere really because i suddenly sort
of it became more interesting to me
especially with the sort of imagined
and i think real guardian audience of
similarly skeptical people became more
interesting to say not look at these
charlatan gurus who've been ridiculous
but like look at this thing that you
might think is a bit embarrassing this
topic or this book or this person
there's actually something really
valuable hiding in that that's just
actually a much more
interesting and frankly journalistically
sustainable thing to do in a column is
to sort of point to valuable things
instead just tear down
how how how did you get the gig how does
one become the productivity columnist at
the guardian i was totally by accident i
was i was working as a feature writer
there and i carried on working as a
feature writer there and my editor on
weekend magazine at the time saw that i
was consuming lots of these books with
this kind of definitely with this kind
of dual motive of like well this is
silly but i'm actually kind of really
interested
and
and she thought
might as well get some
some journalistic value out of the fact
that oliver has this yeah fixation so
that's how that started and it wasn't
intended to last particularly long but
it ended up doing and it lasted for 10
years more than 10 years i think is this
is it
no i stopped it um a bit over a year ago
why did you know
just
it just totally seemed like i it was
finally the right time to do so it was
in the run-up to the this book coming
out that weird thing where you want to
do new things but you feel like you're
actually not going to be able to
motivate yourself to do them until
you've cut the cord of the
last thing yeah which i didn't want to
do i'd far rather get like get all my
ducks in a row and make a make a natural
uh stress-free transition but i don't
think you can do that so that was why as
well
okay yeah that's cool i mean so the book
that you've written is very very good uh
i listened to it on audiobook but we
have a physical version which i would
love for you to sign afterwards um four
thousand weeks time and how to use it uh
you've got oh thank you from darren
brown
durham ryan is one of my one of my dream
dream podcast guests have you have you
read his book happy yes yeah yeah it's
great and i've i've got but haven't you
read his new one
notes on
about a stubborn universe i can't
remember the details but it's um of the
title but it looks like yes totally up
my street yes i pre i pre-ordered it and
it's going to arrive at kendall at some
point at some point soon i hope um four
thousand weeks what is like what's the
what's the premise what's the deal with
that
the title uh that is very approximately
the average lifespan in the west
expressed in weeks if you live to be 80
you'll have what had four thousand one
hundred and something i'm i'm not good
at math i definitely sort of rounded it
to a to an imposing
number
and
you know i i i'm sort of at pains to
point out talking about the title
obviously many people get quite a few
more than 4 000 weeks and obviously many
people get far fewer yeah
the point is just it's really finite and
something about expressing it in weeks
makes it really fine if even if you like
if you break the current world record
for longevity and live to be like what
125 or whatever you need to do um
still only is like six seven thousand or
something it's like
something around that yeah the point is
it's just you put it in weeks it's just
like weirdly
tiny so what's the
the subtitle list is time and how to use
it and i guess when
when i was like describing this book
because i've i i recommended it in my
newsletter a few weeks ago after i
listened to the audiobook i was like
it's
sort of like a productivity book but
it's sort of not really a productivity
book and it's sort of like a
philosophical
exploration of the finitude of existence
i found myself using this weird like
terminology how how would you describe
what the book's about that seems good
enough to me i mean it's really strange
as the writer of something like this
like i i don't think
first of all like now i'm going to pick
a genre and then write into it i
definitely think well firstly what needs
to be said but more in a way like what's
what do i need to hear like because it
it's totally like written for me to
figure out what i
need to do with regard to time as much
as it is to sort of lecture other people
about that and i think that
the point you're making there about it
maybe being an uneasy fit in different
genres reflects the fact that i had got
to a point where what i
wanted as much as anything else was to
understand the the right kind of
perspective to take
not as opposed to
tips and techniques not that they're not
valuable but that they have to sort of
be fitted into a broader
like
sense of what it is to have a
relationship with time and then as as
opposed to thinking that the one next
technique was going to like
be my salvation which i spent many many
years
thinking
so in your 10 years as a as a columnist
for the guardian doing this stuff we i i
got the impression you were like testing
different productivity techniques and
then you'd write about the effect that
they had on your life
yeah that was one of the things it was
also like writing about new research and
new books and stuff but yeah that was a
big part of it and so
i guess
how did how did that culminate in
this sort of more kind of take a step
back more like again like relationship
too timey approach to a book rather than
for example writing a book with like 18
000 tips and tricks the column was a
really useful like experimental ground
for like trying things out and then if
you look in like in the rear view mirror
after you've written the column for
a few years
i could see
patterns emerging things that things
that kept making sense to me and all
that kept
really not working and so both for this
book and the last one i wrote like was
sort of arose from that process you get
to sort of
test stuff out you get feedback from
people someone says i read your column
have you seen this book that's about it
and you sort of act as a i mean this
kind of interaction is much more normal
now than it was in the when i began this
column which is still relatively
speaking the early days of
the internet for for for
newspapers
relatively um
but yeah so that was that was that way
of that that was how it sort of it sort
of started and yeah i guess in terms of
the
substance of the
i
the idea that that kept
emerging from all of that is
there is something to do with
acknowledging limitations embracing
the sort of certain facts
uncomfortable facts about the human
situation with respect to time that that
are
that is very important if you're going
to actually sort of plunge into life and
do meaningfully productive things
and then there's quite a lot of sort of
unhelpful ways of thinking about time
and productivity including in certain
books and coming from certain gurus that
basically just sets you up as being in a
war with
the nate the human situation in a way
that is basically never gonna help
because if your goal is to try to
escape your finitude then um good luck
with that
so what do kind of the
if if we
stereotype a i don't know
the the stereotypical productivity book
written by productivity guru
what does that get wrong or
sort of misguided or different about
product like how do you how do you think
about productivity different to that
well i think the
yeah that's the right question i think
well the most the most stereotypical
book is going to imply that you can
get
everything done that is important to you
whether it's ambitions and goals or sort
of obligations and demands all of it
provided that you render yourself
sufficiently optimized and efficient and
so that you can sort of pack in
uh more and more and more into the same
amount of time using techniques you know
using specific organizational and and
work techniques that you won't need to
make tough choices with what you do
about your time and that if and that you
can sort of achieve a kind of control
over your day
that is basically absolute and over your
life and how things how things unfold in
your life that is basically absolute you
get a sort of subsection of this
stereotypical bad time management stuff
that says no you do have to make choices
and you have to prioritize but it still
implies that like
prioritization and saying no and all the
rest of it is just a matter of
getting rid of all the tedious things
yeah so that all the things that matter
you have time for and i kind of want to
say no you don't even have time for all
the things that matter actually we're
going to take a very quick break to
introduce our sponsor brilliant
brilliant is a fantastic online platform
for learning maths science and computer
science with interactive and engaging
courses that i've been using for many
years but to be honest i wish i'd had
their lessons in maths to hand when i
was preparing for my bmat when applying
to medical school a lot of the time when
we're taught maths at school the focus
is on empty memorization of formulas
that we can apply in our exams but the
great thing about brilliant is their
courses teach you how to actually
understand concepts from a first
principles approach and develop the
intuition to solve problems also their
computer science series is absolutely
sick they've got some fantastic courses
on algorithms on learning to program
with python they've got a whole series
about cryptocurrency and understanding
exactly how things like bitcoin work
from the ground up which is genuinely
fascinating so if you want to give their
lessons and maths a try or even science
or computer science then head over to
brilliant.org forward slash deep dive
and the first 200 people to sign up by
that link will get 20 off the annual
subscription to the website so thank you
so much brilliant for sponsoring this
episode so one of the things that really
resonated with me was the way you
described the rocks analogy i wonder if
you can talk a little bit about that oh
yeah yeah talking of stereotypical bad
time management i mean okay
i feel like caveat one or two people
have explained to me since the book came
out ways in which it's possible to
interpret this parallel parable that are
that are not so ridiculous but in case
anyone doesn't know about it so
in various different versions but it's
like the teacher or somebody like brings
in a jar of should i go through this
whole thing or is it so well known that
this is a waste of uh valuable i think
it's worth going through i'm not sure
it's that i i i it's it's well known to
speak to people like uni okay just very
quickly and yes i always use it enough a
teacher brings a glass jar into a
classroom with um some large rocks some
pebbles and some sand and challenges the
students to fit all of this into the
glass jar and the students because
they're apparently like really dumb
start putting the the sand in first and
the pebbles in first then they find the
big rocks won't fit so the teacher says
no no no let me show you how to do it
and he says so you put the big rocks in
first then you can fit the pebbles and
then pour the sand in and it all fits
and the idea is um
if the big rocks are your major
priorities in life you've got to make
time
for those and you can make time for
those and if you do make time for those
then everything else you can fit in
around the edges but if you don't put
those first you'll never get around to
them at all and i don't think that's a
completely meritless point i just want
to say that right now so that you know
the estate of stephen covey doesn't know
uh
but
the experiment is plainly rigged right
it's set up the the professor the
teacher has only brought as many
big rocks in as he knows can ultimately
with the right configuration be made to
fit and i think
that
extending this metaphor the the problem
most of us have with time management
these days the main one
it's not necessarily that we're bad at
prioritizing it's just that there are
too many big rocks to fit in the jar in
other words there are too many things
that totally legitimately have a claim
on your time too many people in your
life business opportunities demands from
the boss whatever you're setting it
whatever your situation is like there
are just too many things that
legitimately you could use your time on
then you have the time and stamina yeah
available for so the nature of the hard
choice involved is different it's not
just like
how am i going to organize my day it's
like what am i going to neglect because
i'm and what what important things am i
going to neglect because i am definitely
going to be neglecting some important
things yeah like as i was listening to
the book it really gave me a lot of
reassurance
um because
again as a productivity guru i feel like
i should have my life in order and you
know when the whatsapp messages pile up
to like you know 100 plus i'm like oh my
god relationships are the most important
thing in life i'm letting people down by
not replying to them and then i spend
hours replying to all the people and
then responding to whatsapp messages uh
generates more whatsapp messages
similarly to responding to emails it
just generates more emails yeah um
and you know at the same time i care
about the work stuff i care about like i
don't know some sort of impact i care
about spending time with my family and
it's like in the past part of me was
just like you know what i just really
suck at keeping in touch with friends
and that's okay and then another part of
me was like no that shouldn't be okay
like you know i should use my
productivity powers to like actually
focus on this thing that's important
like keeping in touch with friends how
how do you i guess knowing that for
example there are too many rocks to fit
in the jar
how do how does one go about solving
this problem well i think so the sort of
i think the most important point there
is that like in a certain sense you
can't and that's the really important
point and this is not a despairing
message i think it's a really empowering
and sort of thrilling message in a way
but like if the challenge and like i i i
show it like vibe with what you're
saying there about
feeling that there must be a solution
and that all these things really matter
they do really matter you don't need to
persuade yourself that actually some of
them don't matter just to get really
sort of existential about it i think
there is some kind of urge motivating
that and it's almost universal to
want to find a cheat code for
life or find a sort of you know a caveat
in the contract of being being human and
and to get on top of everything or in
command of your time in a way in a
certain way that is just not actually
available to us as finite creatures
because we have this fundamental
mismatch between our capacity to think
of infinite possibilities and feel
infinite obligations
and our ability our finite material you
know
short lives and limited
time so this is like the vague part and
we can totally talk about like more
specific and practical things but but i
think there's something really powerful
in just seeing oh
this isn't a problem to be solved this
is just the way things are at the end of
life there will be lots and lots of
things you didn't get around to doing
that that
totally were legit that there would have
been good things to do but that was
because you were doing other thing
hopefully things that were that were
good things to do and you can sort of
relax into the discomfort of that a
little bit you can sort of you can feel
the anxiety or any way it leads to
anxiety in me that comes from thinking
like well you mean i'm never going to
get to this point in my life where i
have no problems or feel no no it's like
no you're not that and that would be
ridiculous and you wouldn't want to get
there actually but it's a separate
discussion um you can sort of factor in
like price in to your to your approach
to life that there are going to be good
relationships that you don't uh nurture
interesting opportunities that you don't
pursue great books that you don't get to
to read it's like once that's if
something like that is completely a
given it stops being stressful like we
don't beat ourselves up for not being
able to like jump a mile in the air
because nobody expects that in the first
place of human beings and it's a should
be the same for this kind of stuff and
once you sort of
let this whole fantastical edifice crash
to the ground and you're just standing
in the rubble you can be like okay now
i've got this many hours today what
would be the most meaningful exciting
high-impact
things to do and it's like it's
it's hard and i don't want to imply that
i've like totally solved this this this
issue either but like i think that is
the way forward yeah how did you come to
this like realization that in fact it is
not possible to juggle all the things
competently i think the column helps
there in like a weird bad way because if
you test things out for week after week
for many years
and you begin to see what it is you're
wanting from them which is basically
salvation or eternal life or something
equivalent to that
and they it never happens and on the
hundredth time round you're like
oh maybe there's a problem with the
framing of this instead of that i
haven't just yet found the technique so
that's where being a bit obsessive kind
of helps because if you were someone who
just tried a couple of time management
techniques you might well imagine that
the um
that the sort of utopian one you just
hadn't you haven't seen it can't come
across it but i was pretty confident
yeah by the end of that decade plus that
like it wasn't coming anytime soon yeah
yeah i guess it's an unusual position to
be in where you have actually
tried all of the technique i feel i feel
like i've come close to trying all the
big ones through making videos about
this for the last five years and i find
that every time i reread getting things
done i feel about two weeks worth of
like yes capture clarify organize
reflect
and you know it feels like all the
cylinders are firing and it's all good
and then i miss a week of review and
another one and another one
and it's like you know what i've had
this i looked at my todoist which was
the the app i was recently trying out
and it's like overdue reminder do your
weekly review 24th of october
i was like i did it for two weeks yeah
and then the reminder just kept on going
overdue and i was like i know in my head
that doing a weekly review is an
important thing getting all my
priorities in order reflecting on the
week et cetera et cetera but there's
something about it it actually makes it
really hard to do
yeah and i think you know i don't want
to pretend i still totally like a new
app or a new technique i'm still like
there's still a big part of me that is
like excited by that and i'll try it out
and
blah blah blah all that happens and i'm
sure you're in this
um space too is that you you do begin to
just like see through a little bit the
motivations that you were bringing to it
so it's to do with the spirit in which
you adopt a new technique right by all
means try out a new technique or go back
to getting things done or do anything
but like it's when you slightly drop
this idea that it's gonna like save you
yeah from the situation and i've
actually had this really interesting
maybe it's not interesting it's
interesting to me experience of trying
out certain techniques ages ago finding
that they didn't give me what i wanted
because what i wanted was sort of this
kind of total mastery of time yeah
salvation and then years later the
pomodoro technique is an interesting
example of this like coming back to it
in this new kind of
disillusioned but in a positive way um
from that new perspective and seeing
like that's actually a really useful
thing to do it's a great
interesting way to divide up the day
it's like totally useful in for what it
is
absolutely great but
i was bringing something weird
psychologically to it before and i think
a lot of people do that's my gamble
anyway that this isn't just my personal
hang-ups and weirdnesses have have you
come across the midwit meme
no oh okay i'll i'll describe it to you
and on on the youtube video of this
podcast we can put up the midwife it's
it's basically like an iq bell curve
with like 100 100 in the middle and it's
like on the low iq end of the spectrum
there's like this
dude being like um for for example
something like i just do what i feel
like doing on the other end of the
spectrum iq150 there's a jedi master who
says i just do what i feel like doing
and in the middle yeah there's the
person being like i manage my time using
getting things done i have a to-do list
i do my weekly review
yeah all this kind of stuff and i think
this so much applies in the world of uh
in
actually almost almost anything where
it's like
in a way by going through the process of
becoming a productivity guru you come
out on the other end with a just a more
of an appreciation of like actually
keeping things simple is potentially the
way forward
but it's the is this thorough or
something but it's the simplicity on the
far side of complexity right i think you
have to
to some degree you have to go through
that middle bit and maybe one way of
thinking of this book is my attempt to
take readers who haven't gone through
that through yeah the sort of sort of
thing no it's interesting and one
one facet of that just one particular
way that plays out i think is in this
idea of like what have you
been very helpful for me in the terms of
productivity but i think it applies in
other areas what if you just sort of
what if you gave up the idea that there
wasn't going to be any
single ultimate uh solution here like
what if you just sort of accepted that
your techniques and approaches were
probably gonna like change and evolve
all the way through your life like you
were never gonna kind of
get the
set of techniques and approaches and
apps that i mean and that's kind of
obvious in a way that that's what how
it's going to be but there is that bit
in the back of your mind that's like
for some reason this particular new
do everything notes app is somehow like
in
40 years time is still going to be the
market leader it's like i've had that
similar sort of
journey in
a bunch of other sort of productivity
adjacent things like in in the process
of writing the book i have read loads of
books about note-taking about the
process of writing a book yeah and so
like ryan holliday has a method that you
know with the physical note cards and
there's a settle caster method yeah you
know
all of all of these various methods for
for note-taking and i've kind of just
landed on apple notes just writing
things down as like i read them and that
resonate with me and that's kind of what
i was doing 10 years ago as well sorry
it's very inspirational
but then through this whole process it's
like but
but i still feel that there is something
out there and that if i if i did have
the perfect zattlecastern method where
all my notes would link up and all the
insights and then generating a book
would be as simple as copying and
pasting stuff that i've already written
over 10 years right um given that you've
been writing for 10 plus years and i've
written two books does that like
resonate at all yeah no it really does
and i mean one of the things that i
found so
[Music]
there's a there's a quest for
perfect order in that in that kind of
approach to notes note taking
information
which is clearly i think one part of
this overall quest for like total
control over the human situation you
know it's like and it all comes down to
like you know not wanting to die
ultimately i was sort of seeing this
until i and then i after that after i'd
begun to stumble on it in my own mind i
saw it expressed very well by uh david
perrell but these systems kind of you
kind of need to keep them messy in a way
and to the extent that my system of
note-taking and storage of notes is is
disorganized a little bit and it is
disorganized like that seems to keep it
juicier like i get more interesting
insights and it feels like there's more
potential there for new chapters or
email newsletters or whatever it is when
you actually get close to achieving the
level of total control you think you
crave and perfect order the life kind of
goes out of it a bit for me
well like
if i've got a kind of perfectly
organized database of notes like tagged
or folded away in an absolute if i get
to that point where it feels completely
like it's done i don't know how to
express it and i just did like the life
goes out of it yeah the the juice of the
ideas is not so clear if i've got a kind
of directory in some app that has
i'm using ulysses mainly but which has
like which is kind of it's not quite
properly ordered there's there's there's
kind of notes jostling with other notes
that probably should be separated out
somehow like that's when i see the
connections between stuff so like i've
never quite managed to get on board with
the real canonical
zettelcast and stuff where you like link
everything in a very in a very clear way
because the links for me seem to come
just from the fact that there are two
notes next to each other that i that are
not particularly meant to be there so
yeah serendipity i guess yeah like in my
in my quest for the kind of the perfect
system to write the book uh i was
rereading a lot of um austin cleon stuff
around sort of creativity and
having like an analog workstation and a
digital workstation where the analog
workstation like a3 pads and like notes
and bits written on paper and i that
felt this seemed like a very like
romantic way of writing a book that oh
i've got this stuff and then when i go
to my other workstation then i type
things up and i haven't yet tried this
but every time i do get an a3 pad out i
find that just like scrolling stuff on a
piece of a3 paper is actually just way
better
than for example using a very rigid sort
of bullet pointy structure on like
notion or room or any other note-taking
app
yeah and i think that almost the the
more abstract issue here is not
it's not the method but the fact that
any method however good and i like i
love austin cleon stuff for example but
like the the any method if you take it
from that person and it's like now i
must perfectly reproduce it in my own
life it's gonna you're gonna give it a
rigidity that it almost certainly
doesn't have in that in the in the world
of the person
like um who originated it and so i i'm
constantly
changing
the supposed process that i have for
doing these things and i kind of feel
like
i'm always going to be that way and
there might be something
good about the fact that yes that's how
it is i i really like that like i get so
many questions like
you know being a you know as you know
being a productivity guru
one is somewhat financially and
otherwise motivated to continue to try
out different apps and to find the best
one and part of that is this thing of
maybe there is that perfect app around
the corner but like uh and another part
of it as well kind of need content for
my newsletter
so you know notion of just released a
new feature let's like see if it fits
into my life and people will often
discover a video i made two years ago
where i talked about how at the time i
was using notion to store a list of
databases for all the things that i've
ever read yeah being like oh you know i
was reading you i was i was watching a
video about the resonance calendar
you know how do you specifically deal
with this content type and i'm like
oh moved on from that
three days after i made that video
but it feels a little bit fake to be
that person um and so when i was reading
this stuff i was like i i really got a
lot of um reassurance from it i'm glad
there's it's reminding me of a thing i
mean this is making it a bit more sort
of
like this is more to do with personal
life and relationships perhaps but
there's a great
a quote in the book psychotherapist
called bruce tiff to elsewhere not in
the quotes in the book
has this kind of idea that like what if
you took the thing you struggled with
the most in your
psychological life and just kind of
imagined never being rid of it to the
end of your days like so if you're like
if you've got social anxiety or you're a
bit commitment phobic when it comes to
relationships or you're always
struggling to try to bring order to your
to your productivity and your work like
what if you just thought about the the
prospect of like never being shot of
this of this particular idiosyncrasy
and the first i feel like oh like
crestfallen when i do that because i'm
like you mean like i'm never gonna get
to the perfect time but then i'm like
actually it's really liberating it's
actually really liberating to think like
okay
you don't maybe we're not in the
business here of of finding a way to
like
suddenly become to justify our existence
on the planet maybe that's taken care of
maybe maybe you're fine and then
if you come up with some
adjustments to your workflow that make
you even better great nice but like
maybe you're not trying to like maybe
there isn't some like big existential
problem here that you're that your notes
are in disarray in the book you talk
about this and you know in this
conversation so far you've alluded to
that kind of
something along the lines of the the
desire for productivity and control is
is ultimately a desire for salvation a
fear of death like what what what do you
mean by that well this is where it gets
so sort of hard to put into words but i
think we i think
most of us today and i talk in the book
about how i don't think this would have
been true for like medieval peasants
yeah some other people but like we think
of time as something that we're like in
a relationship with and there are that's
not a given um
through the history of reflections on
time but like
and so it naturally becomes something
that we've got to try to sort of use
well or we could be guilty of wasting or
we want to sort of feel confident that
the near future is going to unfold in a
certain way and actually time isn't
really like this so we don't have it's
not it
we're treating it as something that
ultimately it it isn't because
you don't really have time you just get
given each moment as it comes and you
don't know how more much more of it
you'll have and you can't really put it
aside all those things that sort of the
language and the metaphor of like
physical possessions or like ownership
and management right
right yeah doesn't quite work um the
blogger david kane has done some really
raptitude oh
some really interesting stuff on this
it's like so you're constantly
approaching your time
with a sort of set of concepts that
aren't quite properly suited to what it
really is and i think that's because
it's kind of uncomfortable and
ultimately if you go deep enough
probably quite terrifying to
sort of face up to the real truth of the
situation
which is that
each of us
all the time is just completely
vulnerable to anything that might happen
next like you have no
control over the future you can exert
influence and improve probabilities but
like
you are just on this raft
on this um whitewater
river being born forward
and you've just got to sort of do what
you can in that situation and in that
context it's really tempting to feel
like
no can't i come up with a way where i'm
like you know stretch the metaphor like
where i can like get onto the riverbank
and then like control a fleet of ships
or something like no you're just like
you're just in it and that's terrifying
and so i think a lot of what passes for
sort of bad time management but also
lots of other sort of weird behaviors
that we engage in in life are basically
forms of emotional avoidance right
they're ways of not facing up to the
sort of edgy nervous angsty situation
that we're actually in so we we we think
the the way forward is to
is to feel more in control than we than
we really are or to distract ourselves
and
as i say it's a little bit hard to sort
of
articulate in in words but i think that
actually the the better approach in all
these contexts is as to the extent that
one can
to actually acknowledge the way things
really are and to sort of
like go with the fact that you're that
you're on the raft on the white water
and then you can start like navigating a
bit more and use what influence you you
have does that make yes sense the thing
that that reminded me of was and to sort
of
concretize
it please for an example from my life
where i feel like this really applies
it's that the the the feeling of
writer's block in the sense that i sit
on my laptop and i've got three hours i
need to do some writing and then there's
like
i don't know what's going on um
therefore the solution is my my
note-taking system is just not tuned
enough
is the perfect note-taking system and
once i have that then writer's block
will disappear and one of the most like
reassuring things about speaking to any
author like i've done on the podcast or
listening to interviews and stuff is
that that feeling never goes away and
this is supposed to be hard and this is
the work and when i kind of internalized
that now when i have that feeling of
like uh i'm i'm so bad like why would i
even read this et cetera et cetera i
think this is fine all of the people
think of this
so it's all good and just embracing that
then
weirdly helping me make progress and
also be less beating up of myself about
the fact that i've only made a thousand
worth of progress rather than the 2800
that and 33 that i had like decided
would lead to a million worthy or
whatever
yeah no absolutely i think that's so
that that observation that like that
that these things are difficult and you
might get lucky sometimes and go into
like beautiful flow state but but they
are basically difficult um
it reminds me of the opening line of a
great old self-help book the road less
traveled by scott peck which is
i'm paraphrasing but he starts off
saying life is difficult and then what
he says something like this is one of
the great truths because when you um
when you fully internalize the truth
that life is difficult it no longer
matters that life is difficult so it's
like it's like i feel like that's a
different way of saying when you stop
treating
the difficulty of doing difficult things
as a problem to be solved yeah
then
they're not they're less difficult in a
certain in a certain
way and the way i would put that through
like my stuff in this book is like
what's happening when you're writing
is
you're being brought up against your
limitations and your your edge right
you're doing something that matters to
you
the stakes are high you don't know that
you can do it to your standards you
don't know that it'll be well received
but you want it to be so all these
different things are at stake
and so it
it's it's unpleasant in a way
and if at that moment you distract
yourself with some like nonsense
um online or wherever like that's
you're
it's obvious why you would want to do
that you'd want to do that because it's
because the things are not at stake and
it's and and
you're not worried about whether you can
can do it or not another reason i ask is
because relationships are allegedly the
most important thing in life and i i
have always thought like maybe there's
ways to
think more intentionally more
efficiently productively about
relationships and also you've had a kid
recently which is cool um and
i'm always like curious about like i
feel my calendar is overloaded already
and i don't have a kid like what the
hell do you do when you have a kid
yeah i don't really know the answer i
mean it was only fairly recently now
because he's just turned five which is i
i i i i i'll fight yeah look at that
look well i
i i sort of sold the book proposal then
he came along and then the book was just
on hold for like three years and then
got it then so so yeah
nothing will uh mess with your
belief that you can uh control your your
your time and i'm not i don't want to be
i don't want to claim i've figured this
out perfectly at all but i suppose the
sort of just thinking about parenting
just for a second like the
one way of thinking about that is it
does just sort of show you something
very clearly that was true all along
which is that you don't have the control
over the time that you thought you did
and you don't have the capacity to do
everything you
were imagining so you know for many
years
before becoming a parent
i might think that i was constantly just
like one a week or month away of from
of self-discipline and applying myself
to sort of getting everything
totally nailed and
um that becomes again it becomes a lot
harder to continue to believe in that
once like 50 of your previously
available time minimum depends on the
stage of parenting i guess but like has
just been taken away and put to this to
this um totally non-negotiable uh
thing instead and so
it's like
that's quite useful in a way obviously
it's not obviously it's not useful from
the point of view of one's work to have
less time available for one's work but
it is kind of
it it helps one's own
like growth in a way quite apart from
the many many
huge delights of just being father but
like it it helps one's own growth in a
way to sort of see the see the truth of
the situation a bit more plainly which
is like
you know there's definitely not enough
time for everything sacrifices will have
to be made
um and to some extent
this this effect hasn't been as
pronounced for me as some people so i'm
slightly annoyed at that but to some
extent it also
um reduces your distractibility in the
work time that you do get because you're
just like okay
it's just a few hours now before i'm
back on you know before school pick up
or whatever so better get to it and that
does to some extent that works for me i
am still prone a little bit more prone
to
distraction than than i would like to be
but
what are we gonna do about that we are
gonna take a little quick break from the
podcast to introduce the sponsor of this
podcast which is curiosity stream if you
haven't heard by now curiosity streams
is the world's leading documentary
streaming subscription platform founded
by john hendricks who's the founder of
the discovery channel and on curiosity
stream they've got hundreds of really
high quality high budget documentaries
covering all sorts of things from
science and technology to history and
ancient civilizations to food and
medicine and meditation like all of the
stuff in between now the really cool
thing about curiosity stream is that
they support independent creators and so
there is this service called nebula
which you might have heard of it's an
independent streaming platform that's
run by me and a bunch of other creators
and on nebula we can put content like
videos and behind the scenes and long
form longer form stuff without worrying
about things like the youtube algorithm
and so for example in nebula i have a
bunch of exclusive content that you
won't find anywhere else we actually
have the original season zero of the
deep dive podcast which started off as
like remote zoom live streams during the
pandemic and that is only available on
nebula you won't find it anywhere else
so if you enjoy the sorts of
conversations we have on deep dive you
might like to see you know a whole year
before we started this podcast properly
once the pandemic stopped what sort of
conversations i was having with people
on zoom i've also got a series of videos
in nebula called workflow which is where
i deep dive into some of my favorite
productivity tools and on nebula you
also get early ad-free access to my
videos and videos from a bunch of other
creators that you might be familiar with
like thomas frank and tom scott and
legal eagle and lindsey ellis and the
really cool thing is that because
curiositystream loves supporting
independent creators we've got another
bundle deal which is that if you sign up
for an account on curiositystream you
actually get free access to nebula
bundled with that so if you head over to
curiositystream.com forward slash deep
dive then for less than 15 a year you
can get full access to curiosity streams
incredible library of documentaries and
also free access to all of the stuff on
nebula bundled with that so head over to
curiositystream.com forward slash deep
dive to get the bundle deal so thank you
curiosity stream for sponsoring this
episode i always have that feeling of
you know what from next week or from two
weeks from now when the calendar is
broadly empty or you know then my life
will be sorted because all these ad hoc
thing things that appeared this week
they're not going to appear too right
right yes exactly yeah
and you pair that with a tweet i saw the
other day i can't remember who from
saying like all my schemes for
self-improvement depend on my waking up
tomorrow with like five times as much
self-discipline than i've ever
demonstrated on any day of my life to
date so it's both of those yeah
absolutely yeah we were doing a little
goal-setting goal-setting exercise with
the team yesterday uh we had this whole
like business coaching session quarterly
planning and stuff
and i was like you know what's what's
like my number one priority for the next
quarter and it's to write the first
draft of the book i was like okay then i
was like wait a minute that's like 12
weeks in a quarter there's 12 chapters
in a book
[ __ ] that's one chapter a week right a
chapter is like i don't know like 8 000
words probably 10 000 of the editors are
saying we can cut down to like six or
seven thousand so am i really saying i'm
gonna write 2000 words in a day like
each day
and i'm like well
three three hours in the morning it's
quite a long time how how can it be and
so it's just like yeah i will do this
thing but i think it's it's very much
you know as we
as we think about our future selves we
give ourselves superpowers yeah like yes
i will wake up on time i'll be fully
disciplined i will go to the gym like
before eight o'clock and then i'll be
sit sat there ready with my coffee to
write for four hours solid and not get
distracted and not need to do a poo like
in the middle of that yes right and then
the the the reason i mean this is maybe
obvious but like there's a lovely quote
from henry bergson the philosopher and
his book timer free will where he sort
of says like there's the reason that
thinking about the future in this way is
almost always more appealing than facing
the present is because like anything's
possible in the hypothetical future yeah
the limitations of the material world
that you're subject to today are not
there like in your imagining of next
month because you can sort of think like
oh i'll find a way to do this this this
and this or yeah i'll bring more
self-discipline and energy to it than
than before and it's so it's comforting
you get to like you you get sort of
squirrel away in the future so that you
don't need to like face them face the
truth of the situation
right now um
yeah it's useful to notice when one is
doing that i think yeah i think that's
the that's the balancing act like that
that i found as well in my life without
a child um is
where
i will try my best to set an intention
for the day of like this is the this is
the one thing that i want to do
and
i will try my best to broadly stick a
time block in the calendar for when i
will want to do that one thing knowing
that like to be honest if a friend was
like hey you want to grab lunch i will
prioritize social life over work
generally
um and the way i think of it is like
the rest of the rest of the things i
want to do today are a might to do list
rather than a to-do list
and
i i'm i'm still
i'll say experimenting still still
trying to figure out like what is the
what's like a realistic
maximum number of things like i'm
allowed to have on that list
because i think otherwise for me the
temptation is there i'd be like oh well
i'll call my grandma and then i'll call
my mom and then i'll call my aunt and
then okay so that's the relationship box
text oh then i need to message about
eight different friends and i need to
send thank you cards and christmas is
coming up so let me send great gifts
and then i need to do all these
different things checking all these
videos that are coming out and the list
just swells
um whereas what i've been trying to do
recently is just be like i'm only
allowed to do three things on this list
and if after that i still have more time
and i feel like doing like work then at
that point i can i can freestyle it but
i just never get through just just even
those three things on the list um and
one of the things i really liked um
about you also like at the end of the
book you have a sort of practical advice
section for those of us that are like
okay
enough philosophy and we get to the tips
uh you talk about um i think sort of uh
sort of having having like a
a a maximum number of things that you're
allowed to do something to that effect
yeah there's all sorts of different ways
of implementing this and you'll be
familiar with many of them but this idea
of like limiting your work in progress
this idea of saying
that um
i'm only gonna
this idea of saying like i'm only gonna
work on um a small
a fixed number of of things and i'm
going to complete one of those things
before i allow myself to put another
item onto that queue and obviously you
can do this at the level of like
projects you could say i'm only gonna
have like one major goal
um in my work at a time and you can also
do it to some extent at the level of
tasks right you can be like well these
are the these are the three things i'm
going to do and i'm until i've done one
of them nothing else is coming off that
task list and uh
you know kanban
boards are an obvious way to implement
this and i've got this idea in the book
about keeping two to-do lists where you
sort of feed items from an infinite
to-do list through a very narrow limited
to-do list
and again it's just all about like
saying look you're already making
choices your time is already finite
whenever you're doing something you're
already saying no to all the other
things in that moment so now just like
make it conscious and and
and sort of hold yourself to it and
avoid that thing that i certainly am
very prone to i think lots of people are
where
it feels like you're more in control of
things if you just sort of
spread your um attention among 50 of
them yeah but actually it
isn't because what you're not more in
control and you're not making better
progress on them because you just bounce
from one to the next whenever they get
difficult so you just get around that
exactly yeah um i'm i'm finding this for
the book as well which uh one of my
my my writing coach says it's normal for
a first draft where i will get eighty
percent of the way through
and then it starts to feel like uh i
need to round off the argument somehow
but i can't be bothered right now let me
just do chapter eight
and i'm hoping that towards the end of
it then i'll be able to think about this
this kind of stuff yeah on so on the
goal on the goal setting front um i i
also keep on trying to find the perfect
system for this like
um in in terms of like like personal
goals one of my theories
my my philosophies shall we say
is that setting like i don't like it
when i set goals that are outside of my
control for example
when
i set the goal of
i want a youtube video that hits a
certain view count right compared to i
want to make a video i'm proud of when i
think i want to write a book that hits
the standard times my set list versus i
want to write a book i'm proud of and
that's all fine but that almost feels
like it's oh well i'll just do my best
and not worry about the outcome
which also which feels a little bit
unsatisfying
given a bunch of research around the
idea of like effective goal setting and
challenging goal setting and the fact
that kind of high performance inverted
commas in most fields you know it's not
like michael phelps is just you know
what i'll just try my best and see what
happens
right right yeah so yeah any any
thoughts around that tension between
i'll try my best versus i have this
specific outcome i'm aiming for which
may be someone outside of my control
it's interesting i mean i there's a sort
of sub distinction there between there's
the goal there's the things you can
control and things you can't control but
then there's
specificity or vagueness
in the things that you can
control and i i do think that like
things like doing your best and
being proud of things like they're
really important values in life but i
can see how they're not they're not
particularly helpful in this setting
because it's sort of completely
open-ended and so it's not very smart i
know right exactly either you
can either you will end up sort of not
doing what you could have done because
you say well that was my best so i don't
care like and you sort of you sort of
make it easy for yourself or you do what
i think i would do and have done in a
lot of my early adulthood which is like
be convinced that trying your best is
really important and then like torment
yourself constantly with like am i doing
my best is this my best am i can i you
know and those kind of open-ended things
seem unhelpful you on the other hand if
you say i mean this is where i feel like
quantity-based goals can be really
helpful right if you say like i'm going
to put out this number of videos or
this number of i'm going to write
this many words uh
on a by a certain point firstly it's
specific
secondly it's within your control and
then thirdly it's kind of it's somewhat
drained of the sort of the quality of
goals are sort of
they they they go wrong because they're
so sort of emotive there's something
kind of nice about a very very sort of
mechanistic
goal in that area i don't think it's the
whole piece of the puzzle because i do
think even though i wrote in my first
book about like
how positive visualization is largely
nonsense and all sorts of things i do
think there's clearly a role for kind of
envisioning the having a vision of why
you'd like things to be and using it to
determine what you do in the in the
present but that idea of just being
maybe this is like systems versus goals
that is this that old distinction but
it's like it's like the idea of saying
like
this many words
um
or you know just something really sort
of
that sort of takes out all the
all the all the angst from it i think
that's gonna be really useful yeah well
one of the ways i'm thinking about it
because i'm i'm i was writing the
chapter about this in the book like this
week last week um
i intended to do this week as well but
then time goes away like
um
is yeah like systems
i feel like all
all of this stuff converges on a few
central central themes and
we as productivity writers try to put
our own stamp on like a thing which
people have been doing for centuries not
millennia but that aside um
what i'm what i really like is is that
if i kind of break down my implicit
process of goal setting because it's
never been like explicit if i if i break
down what that looked like what it
looked like was step number one
setting a kind of destination goal that
is within my control like write a book
i'm proud of which is like this big
product big project
um maybe in my mind it's like it would
be really cool if it hits the best
sellers it would be really cool if i get
invited on conferences and if i i don't
know get on a podcast because that that
would be sick but like those are outside
of my control so let me just
not think about those yeah and just
recognize that actually it's a you know
a preferred indifferent as as the stoics
as the stomachs might might say right um
so the the destination goal is within my
control and then i'll break that down
into the kind of journey goals which are
is more the system stuff
therefore what i like tangibly need to
do is that every week or every day i
want to aim to write x thousand words or
x hundred words
and again that is within my control
and then kind of my step three of this
three-step process is
for that journey goal that like let's
say i want to write 500 words a day to
lower the bar of quality as much as
possible
yeah i want like i literally write my
to-do list write 500 crappy words for
crappy first draft of chapter two and i
find that putting the words crappy in
there twice
really makes it easier to be okay you
know what this is actually it's actually
doable do it let's do this great
it makes me think of two other things
like um dan harris the meditation
writer and the podcaster um
talks about doing things specifically
meditation uh aiming to do them
daily-ish
and having like having this built-in
built-in fuzziness like because you know
whether you did something dailyish like
in a given week you you have a feel like
if you did it twice it wasn't dalish but
it but it reduces this kind of like oh
if i break my streak it's all over and i
might as well spend the next three weeks
not doing anything
um so i think that's a that's an
important part of that and then
something i found really helpful i don't
know
if this is writing specific but like
might be just specific to writing but
it's also like not keeping going even if
you're on a roll so if you say like i'm
going to write 500 words and you write
them and then things are going well like
i get another 500 it's like actually
making yourself stop and walk away like
that kind of enforced low balling of
your of your aims for the day and like
that's really i think
for people like
i suspect you and certainly for me like
that's really hard to do like when the
opportunity for a bit more productivity
arises and you don't take it yes but
there's this amazing old book that i had
to like buy as print on demand because
it's because it's so hard to get called
um how writers journey to comfort and
fluency by a psychologist called robert
boyce and it's like a really in-depth
study of academic writers and what
caused them to
be either productive or non-not
productive
i mentioned him in the book a couple of
times and like
one of his big findings was that the
writers who made writing into a
a moderately important part of their
lives were did lots more than the ones
who made it into a very important part
of their lives because then it becomes
this kind of intimidating thing and you
have sort of all sorts of angst about it
and you forget about it for weeks at a
time because you don't dare go back into
that scary thing and part of that is
like you figure out what is your short
daily session of writing
and he said like you know
for people sort of amateur writers that
might be 10 minutes a day even for
professional writers it probably should
never be more than like three or four
hours and when it's up you just you have
to stop and like go and do something
else because otherwise you're kind of
giving in to a
an impatient urge to be done with the
whole thing that will ultimately
backfire on you and cause you to sort of
dread uh
returning to the project that ability to
keep important things
relatively small in your life i think
it's like it's really i'm not saying i'm
really good at it yeah but it's really
interesting i was thinking about this
like last night so i i got home from
here at like 7 00 p.m 8 p.m something
like that no like yeah it was like it
was like 8 p.m i was like you know what
i'm going to sleep at 10 30 and get
solid like eight hours of sleep wake up
at 7 30. life's gonna be good i was like
so i've got like two and a half hours
now hmm what do i do with that time
and i said to my housemate and i was
like right lucia i could do some writing
or i could play playstation
while listening to an audiobook
what should i do and she was like well
you know ali
he worked hard to get to this point like
why don't you just play playstation and
i was like all right cool and then i had
a great session of playing ratchet and
clank on the ps5 while listening to the
evolution of desire
on 3x speed on audible and it was so
good i just love the audiobook
playstation experience
um
and uh this reminds me of something uh
do you know
uh greg mcewen
yeah i mean not personally yeah i really
like his stuff um so his his newish book
effortless tells the story of like um
two it's like one of these perfect
stories that i don't know i don't know
how like 100 true it is but like
illustrates the point of like these two
expeditions like the british expedition
and the american expedition to the north
pole or something and the brits were
like you know what or actually probably
the americans were like you know every
single day we're gonna make as much
progress as we can and the breads are
like we're gonna go five miles and no
more and no less on any day
and the americans ended up dying on the
expedition and the brits ended up just
like slow snail snail mailing their way
to just
even
even when it's good weather even when
it's bad weather we're not going to
bother going above and beyond even if we
can and just that that thing in my mind
of 500 words and only 500 words or two
hours and only two hours and then stop
and then i'm just not allowed to do any
more writing right and yeah and it's yes
i think it's great i think and it's hard
right because we
just as a culture and i would suspect
especially people who are interested in
being productive in that culture like
resting is difficult like if i have
doesn't happen very often but if i had
these days but if i have like
two hours to just do whatever i want and
i and i've decided that
it would be not appropriate to use that
to power through my
my work like that's quite challenging
it's like
it does not
things do not obviously suggest
themselves to me in that situation it's
it's better since we moved to the north
york malls because actually going out
hiking in nature is an example of that
that sort of holds my attention while
clearly being not you know
more of the treadmill but like
i think people
get confused because
we've we you hear so much about how
important rest is people know that they
need rest they feel burned out and then
if they ever make it happen in their
lives it makes them feel sort of
antsy at first it's not and and so one
of the i actually talked about in the
book you know it's like you've you've
got to be ready i think if you want to
pursue these different ways of relating
to time
for them not to feel totally great in
the first like half hour or first day of
testing things out because because we
are just completely geared to thinking
that time not spent productively is time
therefore
wasted um
and so like
the first half hour that you're sitting
by the fire with a novel or the first
day that you're at a on a beach for a
week's holiday by the beach probably
isn't gonna feel great and actually if
you know that it's less of a problem
because i think it then then starts to
feel great you know yeah i i think
one other thing that i thought that i
think about on this on this topic is you
know you know this idea of like stopping
work at at any particular time and how
it feels like oh but i could get more
done if i continue to power through
it's just that like
really is and again i'm bad at doing
this but when i do i always feel a
little surge of satisfaction
just the idea that like what am i
actually optimizing for here like yeah
you know
if i think of what i
i guess what i want from my life what i
imagine is a life where
i'm doing some reading doing some
writing and doing some teaching and
hanging out with a team like once a week
and maybe filming a video or a podcast
like that is probably the life that i'm
i'm i'm leading and
finishing my book any faster
and like i don't know getting out one
extra youtube video this week
and stuff like these things that
would be the outcomes of me spending
more time working
it's like
why what's the point like
who's that for yeah right right yeah
what is when is enough what is it enough
yeah yeah and yeah
you know the what i what i try and think
of is
let me
sort of enjoy each day on its own merit
rather than think of the
day as a i guess a means to an end of
having a particular outcome because like
you know journey before destination and
all that kind of stuff yeah yeah no it's
it's making me yeah it's so true it's
making me think of a
time a few months ago when i was hiking
in the middle of a weekday with an old
friend and a beautiful part of the north
york moors it just had come together
that we could do this and
being struck
by the thought in the middle of this
very enjoyable few hours
literally being struck by thought i wish
i lived the kind of life where i got to
do this like i wish i was the sort of
person who could just like
come and do this regularly and it's like
while i was doing it right and so this
sense of like having to become a kind of
person who is so in control of stuff
that you can dispense your time in these
different ways perfectly it's so
powerful that it can stop you seeing
that you're like you're literally doing
it in that moment so i mean it's not
quite the same point you're making but
it's this idea that like you've got to
become the kind of person who x well no
you've just got to do those things a bit
and if things if you value things just
do them a bit and you're and that's
that's the whole challenge so like i
feel like this thing
i'm changing the topic i guess but i
feel this whole thing of like
trying to
become the kind of person who is
actually a really can often be a big
obstacle mind virus
so okay so there is another
cartoon that i've been thinking a lot
about recently which is
him he might be familiar with but we'll
flash it up on the screen and i will
describe it for people who are listening
on on audio it is like a big like an
elephant like a baby elephant in a zoo
and um a kid is there with his dad and
the kid points at the little elephant
and they're like you know why why is
there a like a chain around his leg
and the dad's like oh well you know the
elephants you know is going to escape
otherwise you know this is how they how
they keep it there and then the kid
looks at the big elephant at the mum
elephant and says why is there just a
string around her leg uh and the dad's
like well she's realized that she can't
escape or something like that and
it's like often
the the the reason i think of this a lot
is that often we
chain ourselves with our own assumptions
even though they're not may not entirely
be true and and last night i was having
dinner with dan who is my assistant and
our like one of our one of our team
members um and
i was saying to dan you know i really
wish i could get to the point where i
could i don't know just go to bali for a
week to do like a writing retreat or
something and he was like
but you can like you absolutely can you
know this is your team's your business
we know that you can work remotely
because we've done it we know you can
take gordon with you so you can film
videos while you're out if you really
need to but like you absolutely can yeah
and i was like damn
yeah you're right i i just
had sort of assumed
that i had less control over my time in
control of my time than i actually did
and in a way
it was in a way it's comforting i think
to think
i will write my symphony tomorrow
um totally once life becomes more blah
blah blah blah and
when we face up to the fact that oh crap
i actually could just just do that then
it's like oh hang on
yeah something uneasy about that no
absolutely and i think it's important to
say like obviously the specific example
is not open to everybody many people
aren't in a position to go on a writing
retreat to bali for sure but
no no but there is
there is that same equivalent situation
i think we we do it to ourselves all the
time it's it's related to that um
it's kind of jean-paul sartre and the
idea of bad faith right this idea that
this idea that like and it's in
heidegger as well if you really want to
get into the weeds of this like this
idea that we
that we
that we tell ourselves we don't have
choices
that we do have because it's actually
much more scary to sort of face the
choices that we do have and like no if
you're you
and you have big people have big like
you can
people can walk out of relate marriages
they can um walk out of jobs they can
they can
like
make kind of the kind of public
statements that are going to get them
totally canceled you know that you can
do this like you say you can't do what
you mean is
that the consequences of it that you
predict are are scary and
they may well not be worth it in any
given situation um
but
but like these choices are always there
there's a lovely quote from the
psychotherapist sheldon copp who um has
this whole list of life advice and back
of one of his books and the one i always
remember is um you're free to do
whatever you want you have only to face
the consequences right and and you can i
find this incredibly empowering because
it's like no no you can do almost
anything within the bounds of the laws
of physics and given my financial and
temporal resources
and some of them would have really
really bad consequences so i definitely
wouldn't do them yeah and some of them
would have somewhat bad consequences
like people being disappointed in me or
angry or something and they might
totally be worth doing anyway i slightly
moved that on i don't know if it's quite
no no i agree like um a few a few i
think it was a few months ago now i was
i was i was here on a weekend just
because this place was nice and i was in
the moving house um and i was really
thinking about kind of consequences of
things uh in in in particular i was
doing uh tim ferriss's fear setting
exercise on the what's really the worst
that could happen where i had this
thought that oh what if i just stopped
caring about like the view counts on my
youtube channel and i just like didn't
let it affect me at all what's the worst
that would happen oh okay let's actually
kind of think about this and
realize actually
you know this is actually probably a
good thing overall and there is very few
worst case scenarios here that i i
couldn't deal with
but i i spent the last like four years
kind of on autopilot just assuming i had
to care about the numbers and assuming
that like how well a video does is some
sort of factor that should make me feel
more or less good depending on how well
the video does
and
i think it just like comes back to this
thing of often
we're operating on these invisible
scripts with these invisible shackles
where at least at least in my life and
in my experience like the things that i
would want to do are not the things that
actually have consequences that i can't
handle it's just
where i have made assumptions about oh i
probably can't do this yeah yeah yeah no
absolutely and i think there's a kind of
a comfort as you say as a comfort but
also there's a sort of a false sense of
control in worry right there's this idea
that like if i
i think the reason that we worry on some
level is because we think that we're
somehow affecting reality through our
worrying and it's like well if i
if i let my hands off their controls
there terrible things might happen so
i'm going to keep like i'm going to keep
like fretting about it and the truth is
i think in
it's possibly
a sort of universal truth or it's mainly
just
or it's maybe just generally true that
like the terrible things that can happen
in life like cataclysmic things can
happen in life but they're not part of
the they're not in the realm of the
things that you
might be worrying and controlling about
right i mean like absolutely terrible
things can happen but they will just be
like you'll be blindsided by those
and stoicism has some ways to maybe be
slightly less blindsided but
uh but but like
the things that we worry about we're
worrying about because we think that the
worry somehow somehow increases our
control over them and it just like
it just doesn't so you might as well not
worry about them easier said than done i
think basically in in in every aspect of
my life from well at least kind of from
the time that i
remember vividly like sort of end of end
of school towards university and beyond
i've had
like every few months when i come across
some article in life hacker about
setting your goals and figuring out what
you want and i do like a i don't know
visualization you think of like
you know what do i actually want like
what does like a good day look like and
and stuff every time i do that i just
come up with stuff that i think
there's no reason why i'm just not doing
this now
um
like you know
at one point a few months ago i decided
you know at some point i want to get
into learning how to write songs
i was like i've got two hours right now
like what's what's stopping me
uh all right cool let's just follow
tutorial on youtube and you know
download garageband or something and
make a start on writing songs um
similarly when it came to business stuff
when it came to
deciding to get the studio space and
building a team in person
i just hadn't really thought about it i
was like you know i did one of those
exercises where i was like you know what
does your dream future look like five
years from now i was like oh it'd be
really cool to i don't know have have a
studio or something where i don't have
to have cameras and lights everywhere at
home and to come in on a monday and you
know this there's a team there in person
just like to brainstorm video ideas
about and
yeah interview people in person
and i was like damn
why don't i just do this uh because
before the assumption
and the the invisible assumption i've
been operating on was that when you when
you when you work with a team they just
have to be remote and when you do a
podcast interview it has to be over zoom
i think the the pandemic kind of really
contributed to this right yeah yeah but
it was just such my like my model of the
world was
how how can you possibly hire someone
for an in-person job and i mentioned
this they were like dude do you realize
that 99.99 of the workforce is in person
rather than remember
mind blown um
i don't quite know where i was going
with this but yeah just the the this
idea of occasionally coming back to this
idea of like what do i actually want and
thinking
what are the assumptions that i'm making
that are stopping me from
being there and why don't i just do it
right now rather than next quarter or
next year right no i think that's it's
incredibly powerful and it just reminds
me again of wanting to say i think that
it will feel uncomfortable to do that at
first right because that because what
you're doing if you decide to spend two
hours doing the thing that you've told
yourself you want to do one day learn
songwriting you know is you will be sort
of stepping more authentically into the
real situation of your life it's not a
dress rehearsal it's here it's now
it's limited you better do these things
that matter if you're going to ever do
them
and that will trigger some there'll be
some anxiety or you'll think like oh i'm
not really doing it properly now
like i don't have what it takes to
really get into this now or i haven't
found the right i've got the right
equipment or something you know and you
just have to sort of ride that out a bit
because like yeah yeah oh the
two two nights ago i was at an ed
sheeran concert in in in london uh it
was
it was it was it was quite weird getting
tickets for it because it was like only
2 000 people in like a tiny church and
you had to like pre-order the vinyl of
his album before i came out and i i
don't have a vital play player but i
pre-ordered the vinyl album anyway just
to be able to enter this competition to
get tickets and we got tickets in the
end and he said a very very inspiring
story um so he's got this new christmas
song out with elton john yeah you've
heard absolute banger i've had it
and
before he sang that song he told the
story of how that song came about and he
said that
for the last few years um apparently he
and elton are mates um so elton's been
being like hey you know we should do a
christmas song together and he was like
oh you know
there's all others good good christmas
songs out there there's nothing we can
add to the genre you know also once you
do it yourself or like you know
maybe i'll think about a christmas song
in like 2023
and then he said that a few months ago
uh one of his best friends passed away
um and it made him realize that like oh
my god you know the finitude of
existence and stuff and why am i putting
off like spending christmas with elton
john doing this cool project with like
my mentor and my friend where we get to
dress up as like city christmas
reindeers and stuff why am i putting
that off the letters do it now and he
said that that realization was what made
them put the song out this year rather
than three four four four years from now
i just find that really inspiring of
like you know actually you know the kind
of the stuff that you talk about that
life is short
and if you want to do something then
often
there are relatively few barriers to
actually let's just do it now yeah and
it's very easy to be like oh i will i
don't know i'll i'll uh write my
symphony tomorrow rather than yeah no
absolutely i think it's and i i totally
agree yeah i wonder if we can talk a
little bit about
the end the practical stuff yeah because
i was as i was listening to this i was
like oh this would be a really good book
to do a video about i was like oh crap
i'm gonna figure out a way of like
turning into practical advice and then
very conveniently in the appendix you
have yeah just just use those yeah
i don't think of it like okay there are
ten main points in this video let's
start with the philosophical stuff right
shall we go over some of your ten tools
for embracing your finitude sure there's
a nice little title for her for this um
so number one you say it adopt a fixed
volume approach to productivity like
what's the deal with that this is just
like a general approach to work and i
point out in the book that um you know
cal newport is one of the people who's
writing most uh in the most focused way
about this stuff i think where you
where you sort of you put front and
center your your capacities your the
amount of time you have
perhaps also your energy levels you
think about that first and then you
think about fitting what you can into
that box in terms of tasks as opposed to
i absolutely must get through these 15
things today
and i'm just going to have to like um
find a way to do it so an obvious
obvious example of this is yeah you you
decide that you finish work at 6 00 pm
every day and then
that creates
sort of
uh
that creates a box that's available for
work that day and then you think well
what's the most important stuff to fit
into this box that i reasonably can
obviously it doesn't get you totally
past that problem of um
fitting trying to fit twice as many
things into the box as as you actually
can do but it but it puts your finitude
first and says okay these are the facts
time is limited
and then how am i going to respond to
that situation today
and make the best decisions as opposed
to yeah like i've got to get through
this amount of stuff even if it's like
literally literally impossible that you
ever you ever could okay tip number two
serialize serialized serialized what
does that mean
again related same sort of idea but this
is in this is sort of more longitudinal
this is this idea of of um limiting your
work in progress making choosing
making if you've got multiple big
projects um
to the extent that you humanly can doing
one at a time finishing one before you
move on to the next one and like
expecting to that that will make you
feel anxious about the ones that you're
making
weight
but understanding that that that kind of
willingness to feel that discomfort but
to focus in this way is actually just a
vastly more um
practical way to make more progress and
that when you do the opposite of that
and sort of try to do them all at once
really you're just giving into this this
desire to feel limitless to feel like
you're like taking care of business
you're the air traffic controller of the
world you know um
and and it's it's a nice feeling but
it's actually not the
path to um getting more useful
meaningful stuff done nice love it uh oh
tip three decide in advance what to fail
at and the credit here as i've said in
the book goes to write it called john a
cuff but this is this lovely notion of
like strategic underachievement where
you say to yourself look
life is finite and my capacity are
finite that means that i'm going to be
failing at some things that i that i
might otherwise succeed at that's just
maths that's not that's not a criticism
of anybody
so if you then decide up front
what some of those domains are going to
be
that's actually a much more sort of um
uh
peaceful and happy way to go through
life because instead of instead of sort
of
getting to the end of the day and
feeling terrible
that
the
house isn't as tight as you wanted it to
be or that you didn't mow the lawn or
something you'd be like no
like you already decided for now for
this month for this
period of my life whatever
i'm i'm going to not be successful at
keeping a tidy house and so that one is
off the table and then you can focus
your energies more more on things that
you
do care about i have i have
you know spent long periods of my life
thinking i i wishing i could get much
better at cooking than i am i'm really
not a good cook i think i can cook
nutritious
basically nutritious meals from the
point of view of like feeding my
son and then my wife tolerates those
nutritious meals yeah and it's like
actually realizing oh
it's not going to happen any time soon
that i give this the thought and the
practice that it needs huge liberation
nice yeah i've been i've been saying
that for the last like four years you
know i really should do cooking this
year
and i've just been living off takeaways
and i'm like actually you know what
that's actually fine for this season of
my life right right right as long as the
belly doesn't get too
too large um
oh well what's good number four tip
number five is consolidate your caring i
think one of the one of the ways in
which we um
are sort of induced by the modern world
to do more than we can do is is to sort
of
is to care about more social ethical
charitable issues than we possibly could
so especially with social media
you're going to be you're going to find
out about
vastly more crises around the world and
good causes than you could possibly
focus on
and you're going to be um and everyone's
going to say that their cause is the
most important one in the world because
that's how the attention economy works
you never get a fundraising email from a
charity that says like this thing that
we're focused on is the third
sixth most important issue facing the
world today so can you give us your
money it's always got to be the first
that everyone's in a sort of arms race
in that respect so i just think it's
really useful for people who are who
feel that pull of the duty to like be a
good citizen not everyone does but like
if you do
to think like
when you see the truth of this situation
that there's more to care about than you
possibly could
more than like the greatest saints in
history were ever asked to care about
because they didn't have
global digital communication
that's when you can say okay well i'm
gonna maybe i'll pick
one two issues that really matter to me
i'll dedicate some time to activism some
money to
to to supporting them
and then i will like proactively
decide that the other ones are not my
problem even though they could be really
serious and involve a lot of human
suffering yeah so you could say like you
know what i'm actually not going to be
thinking worrying when i about like what
i can do
for climate change say because actually
like the welfare of
immigrants is my is my focus right and
it's not because the other one isn't
really important
it's that like it makes more sense for
you to sort of concentrate your limited
energies in one and yeah the other one
to someone else yeah yeah i really like
that um there's the
an organization called giving what we
can that has this um pledge that i've
taken that made a few videos about which
is that the pledge to donate 10 of your
income every year to cost-effective
charities
and
you know in this whole like effective
altruism and stuff movement of like hey
how can we do the most good with with
our resources there is there is this
idea of that
yes
you could donate more it could be 11 or
12 or 15 or 18 and while we're there why
don't you stop working at your job and
volunteer at this thing and while we're
there why not like and the list just
continues and what they found is that
look
you know
we all have limited bandwidth to think
about all of these things which are
really really really important and so if
we just set a rule for ourselves that
okay without thinking about it 10 of my
income every year is going to go to the
one of the charities that givewell.org
deems to be the most cost efficient so
against malaria foundation or just to
some isis prevention or whatever and and
recognizing that yes that means that
there are some causes that will be
underfunded and but not not overly
beating ourselves up about the fact that
there's nothing we can do about those
um right i think that's like a nice way
of doing it which is like kind of this
again this middle ground yeah oh tip
seven seek out novelty in the mundane
everyone older than about 25 has this
experience of time speeding up as they
get older right so that your childhood
seems like summer's lasted forever
and then the older you get the more
rapidly time seems to pass which is kind
of really depressing and the usual
advice on reversing it that feeling is
to like have lots of novel experiences
because we process the more data we
process from our experiences the more
the more we remember them as lasting a
long time
um but i'm sort of
incorporating here a point from the
meditation teacher shinzen young who
points out like if you really focus
on if you if you get better at training
your attention to process more data from
whatever you're doing
like that's another way to the same goal
right so it's not just
so it's not just that you um have to go
on like exotic trips all the time that's
great if you can yeah it's that you can
also just like
pay more attention to the things you're
already doing and and you will actually
life will feel more expansive in that
sense tip number eight to be a quote
researcher in relationships what's what
to deal with i really benefited from
encountering this perspective because
it's like i think
if you're
like trying to exert too much control
over life is a problem anywhere but
trying to exert too much control in
relationships
um whether it manifests as like you
being a huge controlling jerk or you
sort of withdrawing and being a
commitment phobe like they're both sort
of
two sides of the same coin it doesn't
work because other people are kind of
endlessly mysterious and infuriating and
that's kind of like the whole the whole
sort of value and point of being in
relationships so this idea that like
of cultivating an attitude of curiosity
so in the parenting context that would
just be
you know can i if i've got like a couple
of hours where it's me and my son and
solo can i sort of like
ask like who is this person like who am
i getting to who is this person becoming
like what's he interested in what what
could we what what does he want to do
that we could do together you know as
opposed to either like i've got a plan
and you've got to follow it which is a
total nightmare with small children or
the flip side of that which would be
like i know you decide what to do
i'm just here to look after you which is
also kind of like
kind of [ __ ] so i think um that that
sort of idea of like oh who like who is
this person i'm getting to know i think
it works in all relationships it's
really i'm not not saying i'm really
good at it yeah but uh it's that sort of
openness to whatever might happen
exactly instead of trying to
have a strong preference for what should
happen yes yeah i think that that really
applies in like the the dating world as
well where i've certainly found that in
in the past i would go on a date with
someone that i like being like oh i
really want them to like me and now it's
more of a
uh it's it's this is a little bit of
that but now it's a little bit more on
the side of i wonder what that's i
wonder what this person is like i wonder
how we'll connect and yeah you know this
idea of being being a researcher like
being genuinely curious to the
experience rather than wanting an
outcome and trying to push towards it
okay so tip number nine is
cultivate instantaneous generosity i
love this idea so much i i really am
so much a work in progress with it but
but um
joseph goldstein the meditation teacher
has has this
this practice that if a generous impulse
arises in his mind
the practice is to try to act on it
right away so if you have the thought
like
i should
i'd like to give some money to that
charity or i'd like to reach out to that
friend and say how much i appreciate
them or send someone some email about
their work that you that you
liked like
do it then
because what gets in the way over and
over again
is not that you sort of decide oh
actually they don't deserve your they
don't deserve it i should just keep
quiet what what happens is you it just
gets it just gets sort of entangled in
the stuff of everyday life or in this
idea that you're going to become the
kind of person i was talking to someone
the other day who said like they'd made
some
pledge to themselves that they were
going to try and like send one or maybe
three i don't know it's like emails of
praise to people who they really
appreciated like every week or every day
or something and of course the effect of
that is to stop you just sending one
email today because you're like oh i
haven't got to the stage yet where i've
already got that habit implemented so
for now i'm just not going to do it at
all whereas of course
the thing you ought to do i think and i
aspire to do is is to just don't worry
about the kind of person you're becoming
yeah send that one note that's really
good this is a this is like ex it's the
exact trap that i fall into when
you know this morning i was like oh i've
just messaged this person who's been
like a good kind of friend and mentor
over the last year
uh i should get him something for
christmas okay let me add that to my
to-do list of
nice things to do so that i can bash
those those tasks and get what i was
like oh yeah i'm thinking about my old
house maybe i should probably send her a
message you know what let's add that to
the list so that when i get around to it
then i will just be able to all this one
go but yeah if instead we switch to the
model of if it is something related to
gratitude then do it now regardless of
what is happening that will probably
lead to a happy life yeah and you'll all
you'll be that person that you're
waiting to become yeah exactly yeah nice
i love it okay that's a very like i'm
gonna change that from like right now um
and finally tip number two don't try
even to do that perfectionistic yeah
right because that's where it all goes
wrong and daily-ish yeah okay um finding
uh tip number ten practice doing nothing
i mean i think this is just generally
excellent advice but but i'm talking in
that section about um specifically about
like non-directive meditation this
approach to meditation where you're not
even trying to follow the breath you're
setting a timer you're sitting there and
you're not doing anything if you catch
yourself doing something
thinking about something following the
breath and
wriggling around you're just like
just stop doing that thing keep stopping
keep stopping keep stopping
it makes you see
how
shinsen young calls it do nothing
meditation
there are books calling it non-directive
meditation um
whatever it makes you see how hard this
is to do to do and it's probably
impossible on some philosophical level
to do nothing at all but but this sort
of action of constantly sort of letting
go of the thing that you're doing
doing nothing is really hard and and and
i think you sort of
you can actually get some good cognitive
training benefits quite quite quickly
from just a few minutes on a regular
basis of really trying to do nothing and
breath following meditation which is so
useful in so many ways is kind of not
that's something different and because
then you're sort of really you can
there's a temptation to like really bear
down on like i'm going to become super
focused
actually doing nothing
for a few minutes it's kind of the
scariest thing in the world in a way
okay wonderful okay so we've got a bunch
of questions
about uh productivity and happiness and
stuff off of the instagram and the
twitter so
i'll just feed this to you and we can we
can have a chat sure so just grace
underscore says how do you deal with
procrastination
that old chestnut yeah
um well firstly i think everything we've
been talking about here is is an answer
to that in isn't answer that question
because i think a lot of procrastination
has this perfectionistic motivation like
i'm not gonna start until i can
know that i can finish or i know that i
can do it well and so anything you can
do to just sort of
fall into reality instead is gonna help
you with um
with that um i'm also really uh charmed
by a technique that i came across in a
i mean it's got other it
crops up in other places i'm really
charmed by this technique that i came
across in a book called um the more you
do the better you feel by i think david
parker is the author it's kind of an
idiosyncratic uh book yeah but he just
has this method
he calls the just one thing method where
you literally like write down on a on a
piece of lined paper a thing you're
going to do
do it cross it out
write another one immediately below it
do it cross it out continue yeah it's
really bizarre
how this should
possibly work given especially for
those of us who have all our complicated
kanban boards and all the rest of it but
it's kind of like this is a powerful way
to get yourself out of a ride it's just
to sort of
narrow your time horizon down to like
what is one thing
that i'm gonna do do that thing cross it
out yeah keep making the list longer
yeah this is basically my method except
that
they should it's it's like genuinely
just that one thing
which is like you know the whole kind of
what's the what's the most important
thing i need to do today um my other my
whole theory on procrastination is
basically i think procrastination is a
problem with getting started and
distraction is the thing that comes
later once you've gotten started yeah
and so
to beat procrastination we just want to
make it as easy as possible to get
started so like
setting a goal within our control
making sure it's just what we've got
it's it's easy enough to kind of make
the time for it lowering the bar as much
as possible to embrace embrace that it's
probably going to be big crap but like
we do anyway
and
kind of even sometimes convincing
ourselves that we're only going to do
the thing for two minutes because once
we've gotten started then at that point
it's so much easier to keep going yes
it's actually just sitting down and
starting to write the first words or
whatever that feels like the hardest
part
um
midwife's ibby
says how can we think about time in a
more healthy way like not in a race to
the finish line kind of way again i sort
of want to gesture yeah whole
conversation whole the whole book yeah
but uh
you know i think that just seeing
just just seeing the fact that the way
we relate to time
is
is not the only way not the only way
it's ever been
done um
thinking about this notion that crops up
in various philosophers that maybe it
makes sense to say not that we have time
but that we are time that we are this
kind of little period of time from birth
through to death and then you can't
really be you can't really be in a war
or battle with that then because you've
sort of
you you you're thinking about it
completely differently it's just it's
just the medium in which your life is
unfolding um if the question was seeking
a more practical answer than that then i
apologize i think um the answer in a
more practical vein is is just you know
all the things we've been talking about
to be incremental to focus on one thing
to
set the goal at an attainable level all
these things just sort of
reduce the
reduce the the momentum of that race to
the finish and bring you back to just
doing the thing that you're doing right
now nice love it
um cyra mahmoud underscore says what are
your thoughts on the four-hour work week
i'm assuming she means the book rather
than the yeah
i mean it had a big impact on me now i
was a little bit rude about it at one
point when i was uh writing this
column uh
because i was a little bit rude about
every successful uh
productivity book but i think you know
um
the the sort of um
business
money-making side of that was not
something that i was that particularly
was my
was my thing but the stuff about
the pareto principle the stuff about
like
figuring out that like 80 that
20 of the effort you put into things
twenty percent of the people that you
deal with deliver eighty percent of the
value twenty percent of the
and eighty percent of the problems that
you have come from twenty percent of the
projects you're involved in that sort of
thing and those kind of that was i mean
it was a like getting things done i
think it was like a really really
important um
sort of formative text
in in thinking about these things in
this new way yeah um you know i don't
think as the best of my knowledge tim
ferriss does not claim that he works
before hours
um
and uh you know so i don't i don't uh
i don't think anyone's getting to an
actual four-hour work week
one of his recent podcast episodes was
the audio for the presentation he gave
at south by southwest in 2007 just
before the book came out and someone had
found like the high quality audio of it
and it's just so interesting to hear
like 15 years later
him from 15 years ago described the
ideas in the book which was all around
the pareto principle this you know
eliminating stuff and
i think yeah yeah just really good and i
think
for me one of the books i had probably
the single book that's had the most
impact on my life yeah uh not for me it
was less from a productivity standpoint
and more from like actually the business
passive income right lifestyle and the
other thing i remember from there is the
idea of um not deferring like the mini
retirements idea
that is totally like in tune with what
i'm trying to get out here in the sense
that it's about like not
not endlessly deferring the the moment
of value in life to some point across
the horizon but taking it now for like
going and doing that thing for a week
uh instead of instead of it always being
in the future nice
um mukund15761
says how did it feel to write the book
was there any sort of regret that you
had about your life while writing it
it's a very interesting question
interesting i mean the process of
writing the book was the process of kind
of coming to understand what i believed
about these things so it was a sort of a
therapeutic act and i was
i was sort of transformative in the
sense that like i couldn't write it to
the end until i'd kind of slightly
become a different person
so it was very very important for me it
was not just a question of like i'd
figured these ideas out and now i was
going to generously write them down
for other people it was like this was
the act of making big strides in my own
sort of understanding of of all of this
i'm not sure it's quite the question
about regret looking back on it
i would say if the question is do i
regret anything about the process of
writing the book which i'm not sure it
quite was but then you know
there were times in that process where i
was
not a pleasant person to live with
because i was so anxious about it or i
was so
deep in the ideas or i was so unsure if
i could carry it off and things like
that you know
and then
and then i think you become slightly
sort of moody presence around your house
and that's i don't think that was so i
think i made a lot of sacrifices to get
to written but kind of my wife did as
well a little bit and she maybe didn't
sign up for them in the same way that
that i had so uh nice
yeah i want to ask you much more about
that at lunch like the whole process of
writing a book um anyway uh noah shoju
underscore says how do we stop the fear
of missing out um
factoring in our lives again i really
i'm sorry but i do think this is a
perspective shift rather than a cool
technique and the the perspective shift
is this
the problem is not that the question is
not how do you avoid the therapisting
out the the the
the trick is to see
that missing out is just completely
guaranteed on an epic scale like
even in eras before our own but
especially in this one
the mismatch between the time that you
have and the time you'll have to take
advantage of various opportunities and
the number of those potential
opportunities is just it's so crazy
that like missing out is the basic
situation in life feel like if you do
like three really cool things today
there were an effectively infinite
number that you didn't do
so like
that's great actually because then you
can be like okay
that ship has failed missing out is
happening
now which of the infinite number of
things that i
could in principle do shall i actually
do i think that's a really
it's really helpful to sort of and then
you then then you can almost get in fact
i think you can get to the state of
actually taking a sort of active joy in
the fact that um that you're missing out
because it becomes an affirmation of the
things you do choose if you just if i
decide
to if i feel like i sort of have to stay
at home at night and give my son a buff
and put him to bed there's room for
resentment but if i see that like
i could have done various things and i
chose on some level to do this one i
mean choice is a little awkward in
parenting because he's sort of like
had to happen but there is choice
involved
if you can see that you're sort of
willingly missing out on
other things because missing out is
inevitable then you can sort of really
become more absorbed in the in the thing
you choose to do yeah it's like the
difference between uh have to and get to
exactly right right yes seeing like
seeing life as a to-do list you have to
get through versus a menu that you're
that you're choosing get to choose yeah
yeah i really like that and i guess like
i guess recognizing this is important in
in in other areas of life as well for
example one thing that aladdin often
often talks about when it comes to
romance is that if we marry someone
and we think that we're never going to
be attracted to anyone else ever again
we're just setting ourselves up for
failure because of course there are a
zillion people around the world that you
could be attracted to and you probably
would be attracted to but the fact is
that you've chosen to spend your life
with this one person and embracing that
rather than trying to go against it or
thinking that it shouldn't happen is
kind of this idea of kind of the the joy
of missing out yes i am choosing to miss
out on these other potential
you know dalliances or
whatever the phrases yeah
um
all right dua tajwa says what is the
midpoint of being comfortably busy but
not too busy in your mind that's really
interesting in the in the um in the book
i write about
i think this might pass
many people in the audience by but i
write about them richard scary's
children's books were they part of your
never heard of childhood richard scary
is american illustrator who wrote these
books called part of a series called
busytown and they're just like these
great super detailed spreads of like of
like city life but all the people in
them are animals so like you know the
the grocery is run by a family of pigs
and the firefighters are raccoons i
think and it's all and they're all the
whole point is that everyone's really
busy but the
but the kind of busy that they are is
not is is that they have tons to do
and you just get and like you get the
sense from
how they enjoy their business that they
also think they've got about the right
amount of time to do all these things
right
they're not overwhelmed he didn't call
it overwhelmed town yeah which would
have been a kind of weird uh
series of children's books and that i
think that i bring this up even though
it's a cultural reference that might
pass most people buy because there's
something really beautiful about that
like it's not bad to be busy people you
know um
elderly people sometimes talk about like
being busy as as a positive in their
lives you know it's like how are you
doing well it's good i'm keeping busy
you know there's lots of lots of things
going on it's like
the midpoint is
being active in the world is great
having a whole ton of things you want to
achieve is great
thinking that you're going to achieve
more of them
than it is
going to be temporarily possible for you
to achieve that's where you you go over
that um
that boundary so um you know
filling
filling life with activities is is a
great thing i don't think that
necessarily having nothing on your to-do
list would be a desirable
state at all
yeah i think i think the way i think of
this is sort of like
uh
climate rather than weather in that on a
given day i might be
very quite busy like jumping from one
meeting to another to another thing to
another thing having breakfast lunch
dinner and coffee with different people
all in one day and that would be
exhausting if it happened every day but
it's quite exhilarating once in a while
yeah and so if i i like to sort of
casually think about you know the the
these last couple of weeks how how has
my calendar felt how has my schedule
felt and if that's like broadly ish yeah
reasonable yeah and then that's fine
because i think there is a trap of
overthinking
like oh on this day i felt particularly
overwhelmed because of abc it's like oh
i mean seasons of life seasons of the
week like it's it's all good yeah right
and there's a very great tendency to
think like if a day goes
if a day goes stressfully oh no is my
life going to be like this every single
day for the rest of my existence and
likewise that if a day goes really well
um and balanced in a balanced way like
oh i've got to make sure every single
day is like this for the end of to the
end of my existence yeah not helpful
thoughts yeah it's kind of like
the weird weird analogy but like when it
comes to posture for sitting and stuff
you know everyone obsesses over finding
the perfect posture but in fact the
perfect posture is the next one and like
just changing your posture every hour is
by far the best thing you can do rather
than getting the perfect economic chair
blah blah blah blah blah
and i think similarly with this sort of
stuff like
actually as long as there is some
balance like
what you don't what you probably don't
want is a you know
very very very rigid schedule where
every day is the same there is it's nice
to have some level of messiness in it
yeah that's kind of what brings the life
into it um and just being a little bit
more like oh pencil sketch about it
rather than inking it in yeah i guess
yeah
um okay question we got a question from
twitter from aparna
gurudwan
how do we decide what matters as we make
most of our decisions based on based on
our current understanding of the world
and we can't predict the future how do
we know that what matters to our present
selves will matter to our future self i
mean i think the first thing to say i'm
such a downer is that you can't know
yeah um so you know we're all uh in the
situation of like feeling our way from
one moment to the next but this is where
i get to mention one of my favorite
questions which i also mentioned the
book from the
jungian therapist james hollis who
recommends that
people ask of certain life choices
they're facing but i think you could
apply it here does this choice enlarge
me or diminish me
um and it's kind of a weird phrasing but
it's as an alternative to like will this
make me happy or unhappy right there's
this there's something about the
phrasing of this question that sort of
i think that most people even if you
don't know whether what you're doing
right now with your life is is
like as making as happy as you could be
um even if you don't know if it's the
right thing or not according to some
value system you've inherited
you kind of can answer the question like
am i am i on a path of enlargement at
the moment am i sort of in some sense
like growing yeah and what's so helpful
about that to me is that like there's
lots of times on a path of
meaning and enlargement that are not
going to be fun yeah
so you could you know if you're
experiencing certain kinds of tensions
and difficulties in a relationship like
this question helps you
um divide between those the kind of
difficulties that are like oh this is a
toxic relationship you need to get out
of it and those which are like yeah like
becoming closer to somebody in a
relationship is tough and has
interesting difficulties and you become
a bigger person as a result of them and
like
you've got to be able to distinguish
between those two kinds of difficulties
in life because one kind you want to get
rid of but the other kind is like
totally crucial to
growth and that question
like
you know whether the job you're in at
the moment is like hard and challenging
and not always fun but it's but it's
something that is taking you somewhere
you want to go versus like it's just
making my soul wither by the day and i
need to change radically you know
yeah
i guess
let's say and again
maybe it's similar to that rock thing
but if you're if you've got like
multiple options and they all feel
enlarging in some capacity
um like like for example i guess kind of
thinking selfishly i could decide that i
want to
take the american medical exams and do
residency in the u.s and do practice
medicine and that would be enlarging in
some capacity i could decide to apply
for an mba at harvard or stanford and
that would be enlarging in some capacity
i could decide to actually focus in
london and grow the team and that would
be enlarging in some past decide to
double down on the book like there's all
these different options for like uh for
things where all options are feasibly
reasonable and feasibly lodging and like
really life is not like long enough to
do all of the things um any any thoughts
there wow yeah like partly i want to
like deliver advice to you here and then
the other part i'm just like no i know
exactly how you feel like about about in
a in different contexts it's like it's
not easy well firstly like one one
response to that is just say
great then then that's fine doesn't
matter which you choose yeah
and then the other would be that you
know
if you if you imagined yourself in those
different paths
and you maybe you know
went to a
quiet place
outdoors somewhere and journaled about
them for a bit would they all stay in
that way or would you would you start to
be able to distinguish the degree to
which other people's or parental or
societal agendas were um
were um
influencing one or another because like
one thing that's so interesting about
the specifically medicine right is that
this is a this is a this is a career
that attracts very large numbers as far
as i can have two kinds of people number
one
people who find it
deeply and profoundly meaningful to be
doing what they're doing in medicine and
the other one people who are like
trying to please their parents who
really wanted them to be doctors yeah or
like society right right right
as like right exactly so that's kind of
really interesting like which side of
that are you on yeah that's so so
fascinating uh how does one get over an
unproductive rut i am going to repeat
myself here because the answer is that
just one thing thing i think part of the
answer anyway it's that idea of like
just
drain all the if you can drain all the
angst out of this just like what is a
single thing there's a quote actually
it's in it's in
jordan peterson's book 12 rules for life
and so i've mentioned it occasionally
and like people get crossed because he's
a very divisive figure but he says this
very non-divisive thing at one point
which is you know um
what is one thing that you
could do and would do right now to add a
tiny bit more order to your life and
this is where they're sort of like
making your bed um cult comes from
like figure out that thing do that thing
reward yourself for doing that thing
rinse and repeat um i think that's
really
uh helpful if you're absolutely kind of
paralyzed if you're really in the kind
of like
not doing anything at all kind of rut
if it's a more sort of long-term rut i
think i think again then something that
is really helpful in the same vein is to
is to of a creative rut which is a
question i think right like is is to
sort of
take the creativity question out of it
so like if you're feeling like
i can't i haven't got any inspiration
for my creative work
then i think it's really powerful to
just get quantitative about it and be
like i'm going to produce x number of
words or one picture per however long
and to sort of turn it into quantities
yes and take out the kind of the
if you're feeling uninspired i think
seeking to feel inspired is not yes is
not the way forward just like turning it
mechanistic into something you can do
for a couple of weeks while you wait
yeah for inspiration to return is
probably the answer yeah yeah i think i
i think also like
i'm reminded of a
i think seth godin was saying this to
tim ferriss when tim was like oh seth
i'm not writing anything i feel
unproductive and he was like well show
me your bad writing and he was like well
i haven't done anything well that's your
problem
where i think often a rut of some
description is in
is somewhat on the spectrum of
perfectionism of like
you know
i only want to do this thing if
it will be good enough it's like well
just do a bad version of it like do a
bad version of cleaning your room do a
bad version of reading a book yeah yeah
and i'm also thinking of another thing
there's a lovely blog post that i go
back to again and again by um susan
piper the buddhist teacher who and the
headline is something like getting
things done by not being mean to
yourself and it and it um
it it relates to this it relates this
experience she had of sort of really
wanting to be the person who like lived
by that credo of like um
amateurs wait for inspiration and the
rest of us just get down to work and how
that turned for her into this kind of
aggression towards herself and actually
sometimes if you weren't going to do
anything anyway because you're in such a
rut then you might as well ask the
question like what would be most fun to
do today because it's not going to be
worse than sitting doing absolutely
nothing and feeling miserable yeah yeah
i often find this in the evening
sometimes where it's like i i can choose
to be dissatisfied with what i've done
for the day or i can choose to just
simply choose to not be dissatisfied
with that i should just do something fun
off it is just a conscious choice of
like do i want to continue to tell the
story to myself that beats myself up
about this thing because either way it's
not going to change how much i've done
right right no exactly what it's going
to change how i feel about myself which
is all that matters
um and i sometimes like i sometimes
argue this point with my mom where she
says you know
oh the only reason you're you're saying
that is to make yourself feel better
about yourself i was like well yes yeah
that's the point
why would i tell myself that story
though right
but yes um anyway final question from
twitter uh oh i guess the question is in
two parts one
is it worth um underscore times five in
baran says is it worth pursuing
something that matters to me but isn't
sustainable to do but might be in the
future
i can sort of think i can sort of
imagine context where that might
apply right you you kind of there might
be things you really want to do you
don't think you can make them pay for
example and they're really important to
you
but maybe one day you could make them
pay yeah i mean
i i i mean
yes yeah i mean
i think i think it's i think it's
worthwhile to do things that matter
that's virtually a tautology and and you
know one way to think about that is not
to define mattering as and i do get into
the sections but i don't define
don't set a don't set a definition of
mattering that is so high
that almost everything worthwhile in
life fails by comparison against it so
for some people that's like
don't some people like don't think that
they can be novelists if they can't be
tolstoy and some so it's like sort of
like you know historic level kind of
mattering but other people might say
like you know what's the point in
spending the next two years doing x
because i don't think i can
i don't think it's feasible to spend the
next 40 years doing x well
there might be reasons to not do that
depending on your sort of highest goals
for your life but that's not a good
reason to to decide that something
doesn't matter yes it can matter
to do for yeah a couple of it can matter
seasonally a couple of years absolutely
it can matter for a couple years and
then you move on to something else and
it mattered because otherwise again
you're just sort of storing everything
up to this like alleged deathbed moment
yeah no i think i i think it's
everything's great now yeah i think this
is a trap a lot of people fall into
which is and i certainly do as well
which is the um
[Music]
if i cannot do this forever there's no
point doing it now like oh
i don't want to start a youtube channel
because i'm not going to be youtube in
my 50s like well okay
that's not a good reason to not start a
youtube channel maybe there are other
reasons like you're scared or you don't
value it or whatever but like i don't
see myself doing this 30 years down the
line is absolutely not a good reason
similarly when it comes to
you know uh
one one thing
we're talking about with with gordon
who's been a personal trainer for 12
years is can we do like a sort of body
transformation for me over a period of
maybe six months where you know work out
four times a week eat super healthily
try and i don't know get on the cover of
men's health magazine just for the bands
and it's not sustainable like obviously
but that's fine it doesn't need to be
it's a bit of fun to happen in the short
term and even then it will probably it
happens which will it's going to promote
like healthy eating and it's going to
promote some good habits yeah recognize
it yeah which
yeah and like what is life other than
like some episodes of things that you do
until you're not doing them anymore all
right so you might as well make them
meaningful ones in the moment yeah yeah
absolutely
um
and finally what are your thoughts on
the idea
that
oh
okay so there was this tweet that came
out a few days ago
i suspect the person who wrote the tweet
did it
ironically
like knowing that this was going to rile
people up the wrong way okay and lots of
people have become riled up the right
way so i'll just read the twitter
twitter
hot take the easiest way to put yourself
behind in life is going traveling for
months on end in your early 20s to quote
find yourself it's an absolute success
killer and puts you behind the majority
why waste the key years of your life
meant for building and getting ahead so
that's the tweet which a lot of people
are dunking on because it it's just
obviously bad
and i guess this person wants you to
also dunk on that like what are your
thoughts on right like that yeah
exploring yourself is like a success
killer and we want to get ahead in life
get down to business yeah
found theranos yes be on your way
exactly well the first thought i have
about that is that like it is
it's obviously
nonsense from a certain perspective
which is the perspective i most
naturally want to take
there might be industries where that is
like true relative to that industry like
i don't know and i wouldn't want to ever
like give people terrible advice because
i don't know their industry i can i'm
sure there are
um
like
places where the path of advancement is
is structured in such a way that that
becomes
true for that industry i think it's like
it's pretty true in medicine right you
spend your 20s like striving for this
thing such that you can then enjoy life
in your 30s or 40s
so firstly you have to see that it's
relative to that industry so the
question is does success in that
industry matter to you more than
anything else and matters to you more
than exploring and finding yourself in
your 20s and it might do
um
and then if it turns out that that was
the wrong path you can always go and
explore and find yourself in your 40s i
mean like plenty of people do that but
no i mean it's obviously not it it's a
it's a comment that you're going to tell
me now it's
made by some like close friend or
somebody i want to like me or something
no no
i don't know who that is it's all good
um
that
like it's a it's a it's a it's an
observation that
that takes as read precisely the thing
that we're
like or should be debating here which is
like what is a meaningful life for you
it's it assumes that professional
advancement in the industries where this
applies is the thing that matters the
most and then it says well don't do this
other thing it's like maybe if you're
someone who for whom what matters um
sifts out that way but if you're not
then it's
kind of ridiculous i think it mainly
just shows that that kind of very
specific advice then offered to
literally everyone yeah as if it would
apply to them all is just uh is is is
crazy i do i i don't really know if we
kind of touched on this but do you have
a theory on how to how to figure out
what actually matters to us big question
yeah i mean well the enlargement of
diminished stuff that we talked about is
a part of it um and then i was very
conscious and deliberate writing this
book for example of not wanting to offer
a laundry list a lot wanted to be like
oh
relationships time spent in nature
getting enough sleep you know it's like
either people know all that anyway or
oh it's gonna be lost in them anyway
right right whatever you know i i can't
help you with that um
and i'm not necessarily a sort of
great exemplar of it either i think
basically
most people certainly my real experience
of this question is just in terms of how
it how it goes in life
it's not a question of like you you
spend a week at a retreat and you figure
the answer to the sound and you never
return to it lots of books that i
remember criticizing in my early days in
the the garden column you know they give
this idea that you're gonna it's like
first of all figure out your like
corvettes
now once you've done that and you're
like hold on a second
yeah like and i think that seeing it as
seeing these things as part of as a as a
as a part of the journey that is always
there on the journey right so i think
like
i think it's helpful to think of
the process of being alive and moving
through life as the process of
clarifying what a meaningful life is for
you um instead of this i mean i'm not
saying it can't
help sometimes to like go and spend two
days coming up with a vision statement
but like that
that's gonna then change and have to
adapt within within days presumably i
think that idea that you're gonna sort
it out that we all have a single stable
purpose and then you've got to just
spend the rest of your life executing on
this insight you had i just i don't know
anyone for whom that worked that way and
it certainly didn't for me yeah great
i've tried all these exercises and
they're just like some of them have have
been useful but in the sense that um
they just give clarity and we it they
encourage us to ask the sorts of
questions we just wouldn't normally
right um but i think i just come back to
that like uh tightness of gripping
metaphor that you that you said earlier
which is that
gripping too tightly to a vision
statement or values or anything like
that it's not that the values of the
problem it's that the the the tightness
of gripping is the problem yeah and we
relax our grip and be a little bit more
chill about it yeah yeah and it's great
to put time and thought into
um you know your plan that is just a
statement intent in the present moment
it's thinking that your plan is anything
more than that yeah yeah there's a
problem nice
um so we normally wrap up with a series
of just some quick fire questions
question number one uh what piece of
advice would you give to your younger
self the feel of this is very easy i'm
trying to phrase it right i mean it's
basically
um
it's basically something like you don't
need to
struggle so hard to like justify your
existence on the planet
that's a little bit candid that's good i
love it
uh who has had the biggest influence on
your career that is a really
hard question to answer i'm i think that
um
two
editors at the
guardian ian katz and marip mills made
probably had the biggest like
opportunities they offered me all things
they saw that figured out that i could
do with their with their under their
guidance probably made the biggest
difference but
they're also like
the very first people who got me my very
first start before that and then my
parents like i could answer that
question a million ways what is one tip
for someone looking for success
wow
um
yeah uh
um
uh focus on one thing at a time nice
uh what does the first and last hour of
your day look like whole day as opposed
to working day i've talked about my
first hour get up about 5 5 30 ish drink
coffee write in my journal um
last hour
is um
sort of stumble around in a in a
bleary-eyed state uh sort of closing
down the house and uh um
having sort of probably read to my son
and then um
uh
sort of
reading or listening to a podcast until
i fall asleep it's not very interesting
that's good
it's the truth
the productivity gurus
um what's
one physical thing maybe
under 100 pounds or thereabouts that has
added disproportionate value to your
life well the tiny little digital
kitchen timer that i think was 20 pounds
that i carry everywhere and have in my
bag right now um uh certainly i do use
that for like sort of
various
um ad hoc
time boxing operations uh so so that's
uh
that's at that price point instead of
your phone that's probably true
yeah i just it's it's separate yeah it's
like my phone can be put away while i'm
focusing it buzzes yeah
and it doesn't have doesn't lure me into
other things it's it's single single
task technology i'm really really yeah
you talk about that i'm really in the
book as well um at a different price
point it's not under 100 but it just
relates i'll just mention it if you're
interested i i have this um
this tablet called remarkable oh do you
like it i i i'm loving it no way no i
tried it for a few weeks and went back
to the ipad like why why do you like it
uh it's just yeah it's just so quiet you
know it's like mentally quiet it's just
like i'm not going to click away into
other things it's just paper except it
has a few benefits and a few downsides
compared to paper but like that and it's
just like it's physically a pleasure to
it is nice to write to write on yeah um
maybe i should dump my remarkable too no
maybe it's not maybe it's not for you
because i do really like the kindle for
that like right as opposed to reading on
a phone or an ipad just because there's
zero chance of getting distracted yeah
and the only thing i could get
distracted by is another book which is a
good distraction right exactly you end
up sort of like searching the kindle
store in order to not focus on the book
you're reading but that's okay that's it
um what book other than your own would
you recommend it to anyone at a certain
point in life i would recommend a book
called finding meaning in the second
half of life by james hollis who i've
mentioned although um
there may be people in the audience here
who are like it's a bit of a midlifey
kind of second half post-40 or
post-marriage
uh well i mean midlife in the jungian
sense
can be anything from like about 35 to
70 i think when that sort of moment
comes so like you know it's probably not
for people in their early 20s although
james hollis has written things that
that could be fair definitely could be
for everyone um
i'm just trying to think if there's a
if there's a book that uh
is yeah so what's something you'd
recommend to me like you've had a look
at my bookshelf we broadly read the same
stuff
yeah is there anything kind of a bit off
the beaten track
like maybe that didn't hit the new york
times
yeah that you found really interesting
let me think i will get there i'll just
need to you'll need to cut out the bit
where i'm just sitting here
into my brain it seems like you read a
lot of philosophy stuff which i haven't
read like i feel like i need to start
reading a bunch of this stuff because it
all
is is all the stuff that
we read about just a thousand years ago
yeah i mean i think you know and the
certainly the the stoics in the original
are really that's not a problem to read
heidegger i kind of made a show in the
book of how difficult it was to grapple
with heidegger i do not recommend that
people
like go and read uh
being in time uh just for
fun because that is so uh
crazy on the writing front it's not a
new it's not a new observation at all
but bird by bird by anne lamott is a
really really good book about writing
i've heard it sound like you haven't
heard of it wow we can introduce it to a
new generation anne lamott bird by bird
uh instructions on writing and life
oh sick all right i'll get that kendall
right now i guess the next question is
more like applies to
entrepreneurs but i i
guess in your case yeah you are
basically an entrepreneur um if if you
lost everything let's say some level you
got cancelled you lost all your money
lost all your following
didn't have the books don't have the
publishing deals what would you do to
rebuild because it depends how canceled
i was because you know the the thing
that i would do
um
based on my skills and contacts right
now is i would
reach out to various editors for whom
i've written things in the past and see
if they want to be directed but if i've
been if the idea is that i've been
canceled so much that none of them will
talk to me yeah or that's kind of in
this hypothetical version you're kind of
starting from scratch right yeah
you don't have anything other than the
skills that you've developed right yeah
that's interesting on one level i sort
of have explored all these different
areas and i feel like i know quite a lot
about quite a lot of different areas but
on another level there is one skill that
i have which is like talking to a bunch
of people reading a bunch of stuff and
turning it into pieces of writing so i
think i would have to like so i guess
how the idea is is the idea of the ideal
answer sorry to make a heavyweight of
course is the idea that you're going to
say you're going to find a totally
different profession where the same
things apply or is it just that you like
start again because i think i probably
would have to just like write stuff yeah
i mean it makes a lot of foreign
i guess the question is sort of aimed at
sort of people in their probably early
20s or late teens who are trying to
figure out what to do with their lives
and want to find like a path to i don't
know salvation
i mean i think you know i think i'm
fascinated i don't think i'm not saying
i could do it yeah i'm kind of
fascinated because i think i'm probably
too self-centered but i'm fascinated by
the career of by the careers of like
psychotherapists like analysts people
like that um
i think that would be very very
interesting
um i could probably be an academic of
some
some kind but i'm not sure i'd want to
be i'm really lamely answering this
question i don't know is the answer
yeah like how how hard would it be to
get
to
how hard is it for someone to be a
professional writer these days if that
makes sense as a question
i mean it depends on what you mean if
you mean can you make exclusively make a
handsome living solely off the income
from books themselves then that's a very
small number of people i think um or
it's people who are so frugal that
they're able to make their book advances
um
spread out over multiple years i guess
as a writer there are other business
models right no no and if you mean you
know if you mean to have a book
get an advance for the book
build an audience do certain kinds of
paid work that you wouldn't have got in
the absence of the book like i mean
there are more of them and i'm one of
those people i think now um
probably more than i am a freelance
journalist in terms of the day-to-day
content of my work but if people think
it's like
you sell
you sell like
millions of books then you make huge
amounts of money on each one like none
of that applies
except maybe to like you know five
people on the planet yeah it's like i
think it's kind of how
being a youtuber
yes there are five people on the planet
who are making stupid amounts of money
off the back of their youtube channels
but there are plenty more who are making
stupid amounts of money off the back of
the youtube channel plus the other
things that offer you off that and just
thinking more intelligently about the
business model and
you're making a course maybe writing a
book maybe like sort of doing the other
stuff that becomes available as an
offshoot off of sharing something you
enjoy and building an audience around
that thing
i think if i if i lost all the things i
would probably just
do that again because it's a skill like
and it takes some time and it's kind of
fun and
so yeah yeah yeah
yeah again i'm responding to the thought
experiment by questioning the premises
of the thought experiment which is an
obnoxious thing to do
okay what
feel free to
question the purpose of this but uh what
quote or mantra do you live by there
isn't just one that i'm thinking of
every single day but the ones that
spring to mind
as partly i've mentioned james hollis
does this choice enlarge me or diminish
me uh sheldon copp um you're free to do
what you want you have only to face the
consequences
and um
uh
a question that i think i i i'm
borrowing from a conversation i heard
sam harris talk about he wants his is
once having where he was moaning about
his
problems in his work or something to
somebody and she responded like hold on
do you think you're
are you under the impression that one
day you're going to get to a stage in
your life where you don't have problems
um so some formulation of that it's like
no the problems are
quite my wife now but like sometimes
when i'm complaining about
the problems
that are keeping me from getting down to
the the meat of my job she'll say based
on her own understanding that she
learned in her own work like
no no the problems are the job and like
that's a very
freeing thing to realize that like
that you're not going to get to the
point of without problems that's not a
mantra wow that's a long mantra like 350
word mantra
yeah the problem isn't it the problems
never really go away they just change in
their like glamorousness right and you
get to choose some really great ones
yeah if you're lucky but there's still
problems yeah right and finally uh
journey or destination that i've got to
question that dichotomy
okay
what that
i you know i
i don't accept the
distinction
what do i mean by that i'm not sure what
i mean by that let's just say journey
but i think that there's something of
the destination in every moment of the
journey there you go oh join my cult i
love it
all right oliver thank you so much this
has been absolute joy um bit of pleasure
any anything you would like to plug to
the audience we will have links to the
book guys really we'll get it on audible
um because you
read the audiobook narrated by me the
book is available all the places you'd
expect my books um
and then at my website oliverbeckman.com
there's more stuff and you can sign up
to my email newsletter which i call the
imperfectionist oh it's nice it's a good
name thank you i love it all right
thanks cheers and thanks for listening
everyone we'll see you later all right
so that's it for this week's episode of
deep dive thank you so much for watching
or listening all the links and resources
that we mentioned in the podcast are
gonna be linked down in the video
description or in the show notes
depending on where you're watching or
listening to this if you're listening to
this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the itunes
store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full hd or 4k on
youtube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching do hit the subscribe
button if you aren't already and i'll
see you next time bye